Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. And we are aware we've probably got lots of new listeners. We've dominated, we've done an episode on ukraine haven't we we've done four episodes on recent history of russia and those are episodes that have very much been generated by what is in the news headlines but we just wanted to tell new listeners that not every episode we do is necessarily prompted by what's going on in the news and in fact our aim is very deliberately to sweep as far and wide that's right tom we've
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告播客、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。我们知道我们可能有很多新听客。我们做过一期关于乌克兰的节目，不是吗？我们还针对俄罗斯的近代史做了四期节目，这些节目很大程度上是由新闻头条所引发的，但我们只是想告诉新听客们，我们并非做的每一期节目都必然是由时事新闻所触发的，事实上，我们的目标非常刻意地放得极其广泛，没错，汤姆，我们
done everything from the andertals to the 1990s we've done episodes on um on on sort of prehistoric paganism we've done episodes on the roman empire um on on sort of the beatles on the dinosaurs on the oil crisis on the lots of top tens we've done um top ten units yeah top ten mistresses top ten most disastrous parties so um something i hope for everybody to taste uh and if you are a new listener and you would like to sample um some of the other episodes you'll find links to them uh everything from uh alexander the great to watergate in the program description uh wherever you get your... That's right, we've got links to some of our most popular episodes.
做过从尼安德特人到20世纪90年代的各种内容，我们做过关于史前异教的节目，做过关于罗马帝国、披头士乐队、恐龙、石油危机以及很多十佳盘点的节目，我们做过十佳什么？是的，十佳情妇，十佳灾难派对。所以，希望每个人都能在这里找到自己感兴趣的内容。如果你是一位新听客，想要试听我们的一些其他节目，你可以在节目简介中找到它们的链接——从亚历山大大帝到水门事件，无论你在哪里收听……没错，我们精选了一些最受欢迎的节目的链接。
And if you then go back into our feed, you can listen to all the previous episodes. And if you find you like what you hear, you can always join the Rest Is History Club at restishistorypod.com, and that is unbelievable value. And you get all kinds of treats and benefits, don't you, Tom? You get sensational benefits. You do indeed.
然后，如果你翻看我们的过往节目源，你可以收听所有以前的节目。如果你发现你喜欢你所听到的一切，你随时可以加入在 restishistorypod.com 上的“历史的余烬”俱乐部，那里的价值简直难以置信。你会得到各种各样的福利和好处，不是吗，汤姆？你会得到轰动性的福利。确实如此。
Right. We've probably promoted ourselves on our own podcast for long enough. So on with the show. To Mexico. Hello. Welcome to The Rest Is History. In room 44 of the National Gallery in London, there hang the fragments of a large unfinished painting
好了。我们在自己的播客里做自我宣传的时间大概也够久了。那么，节目继续。前往墨西哥。您好。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。在伦敦国家美术馆的44号房间里，悬挂着法国印象派画家爱德华·马奈一幅大型未完成画作的残片，
by the French impressionist Edouard Manet, entitled The Execution of Emperor Maximilian. In the centre stand the members of a firing squad, their rifles levelled. On the right, an officer is making the final adjustments to his own rifle. And on the left, well, the only hint of the condemned man is his hand. That's all we see of Maximilian von Habsburg-Lothringen, Emperor of Mexico.
题为《处决马克西米利安皇帝》。画作中央站着行刑队的成员，步枪已经平举。右侧，一名军官正在对自己的步枪做最后的调整。而在左侧，嗯，关于这位死刑犯唯一的暗示就是他的手。这就是我们能看到的全部关于马克西米利安·冯·哈布斯堡-洛林（Maximilian von Habsburg-Lothringen），墨西哥皇帝的景象。
The rest of him is missing. And Tom Holland, there is a metaphor there, isn't there, for the extraordinary, colourful, strange story of this ill-fated man. It is. And do you know, I mean, I kind of vaguely had an awareness of it. Principally, I have to say through the Manet painting. And reading up about him and discovering more about him, it actually reminds me a bit of General Gordon.
他的其余部分都不见了。而汤姆·霍兰德，这里面有一个隐喻，不是吗？关于这个命运多舛的人那不勒斯般、丰富多彩且离奇的故事。确实。你知道吗，我的意思是，我对此其实有一种模模糊糊的意识。主要来说，我必须承认是通过马奈的那幅画。而通过阅读关于他的资料并更多地了解他，这其实让我想起了一点戈登将军。
Yes, there's definitely General Gordon. So the plot is, I mean, this is a guy who is a Habsburg Archduke and he goes off to Mexico. And I don't think we're giving any spoilers. Well, no spoilers, because you've already given it away. I mean, he ends up in front of a firing squad. So there is a kind of slight parallel with Gordon, except that this story has a distinctively Latin American quality. And it comes across absolutely brilliantly in a new book, The Last Emperor of Mexico, by Edward Shawcross, which I thought, I mean, it has, I don't know if you've read the Louis de Bernier novels that he wrote before Captain Corelli. They're a kind of riff on the theme of
是的，绝对有戈登将军的影子。所以这个情节是，我的意思是，这家伙是个哈布斯堡大公，他去了墨西哥。而且我想我们并没有剧透什么。好吧，没有剧透，因为你已经说漏嘴了。我的意思是，他最后站在了行刑队面前。所以这与戈登有那么一点小小的相似，除了这个故事有着鲜明的拉丁美洲特质。它在爱德华·肖克罗斯（Edward Shawcross）的新书《墨西哥末代皇帝》（The Last Emperor of Mexico）中得到了非常精彩的展现，我觉得，我不知道你有没有读过路易斯·德·贝尔涅尔（Louis de Bernieres）在《柯莱利上尉的曼陀林》之前写的小说。它们是对
Latin American magical realism. You know, so Thomas Aquinas turns into a hummingbird, that kind of stuff. And this story is so odd. It's so bizarre. It's so kind of Baroque. It's very magical realist, isn't it? And it's so brilliantly told that it is a great privilege for us to have the author with us on the show.
拉丁美洲魔幻现实主义主题的一种变奏。你知道的，比如托马斯·阿奎那变成了一只蜂鸟，诸如此类的事。这个故事太离奇了。太古怪了。太有点巴洛克风格了。非常有魔幻现实主义色彩，不是吗？而且它讲得如此精彩，能够邀请到本书的作者来到我们的节目中，是我们莫大的荣幸。
Ed, thanks so much for joining us. We both enjoyed this book so much. And it is an amazing story. And as I said, this is a story that probably isn't widely known. So let's kick off with a question from Harry Lloyd Prentiss, who asks, who was the last emperor of Mexico? For now. That's true. Well, thank you for that fantastic introduction so the last emperor of mexico um is ferdinand maximilian and he's a hapsburg but of course he's the younger brother or a younger brother of franz joseph the emperor of austria uh now maximilian is a man who's absolutely convinced of his destiny to rule uh and it's only by an accident of birth that he's not the one who's
埃德，非常感谢你加入我们。我们俩都非常喜欢这本书。这是一个惊人的故事。而且正如我所说，这是一个可能并不广为人知的的故事。那么让我们从哈里·劳埃德·普伦蒂斯（Harry Lloyd Prentiss）的一个问题开始，他问：谁是墨西哥的末代皇帝？目前是的。这倒也是。好吧，谢谢你给出这么精彩的介绍，所以墨西哥的末代皇帝，嗯，是斐迪南·马克西米利安（Ferdinand Maximilian），他是哈布斯堡家族的人，但当然他是奥地利皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫（Franz Joseph）的弟弟，或者说年幼的弟弟。嗯，现在马克西米利安是一个绝对坚信自己注定要统治的人，而且仅仅是因为出生时的意外，他才不是那个
going to be in charge of the austrian empire Now Maximilian, he's an interesting character, very different from his brother. They're very close when they're young but when Franz Josef becomes emperor of Austria in 1848 the characteristics that separate them become more important. So Franz Josef is very autocratic, rigid and conservative. Maximilian is much more outgoing, gregarious and liberal. And what do you do with a younger brother who's outgoing, gregarious and liberal? You keep him far from power. So that description of the slightly rigid, dutiful elder brother who goes on to attain a royal position on the throne, and the slightly dreamier younger brother who ends up going to to america dominic does that remind you of tom and james holland right um it's surely it's william and harry isn't
将要掌管奥地利帝国的人。现在，马克西米利安是一个有趣的人物，与他的兄弟截然不同。他们年轻时关系非常亲密，但当弗朗茨·约瑟夫在1848年成为奥地利皇帝时，将他们区分开来的特征变得更加重要。因此，弗朗茨·约瑟夫非常专制、刻板且保守。马克西米利安则要外向、合群得多，也更加自由派。你该怎么对待一个外向、合群又崇尚自由的弟弟呢？你得让他远离权力。所以对那个稍微刻板、极具责任感的大哥的描述，他最终登上了王位，而那个稍微有些梦想主义的小弟弟最终去了美洲，多米尼克，这有没有让你想起汤姆和詹姆斯·霍兰德？对了，嗯，这难道不肯定是威廉和哈里吗？
it oh really i would never have guessed yeah but the difference is that well we'll we'll explore some of the differences but yes so so just to put this into context um maximilian was born in 1832 i think so two years younger than Franz Joseph. Is that about right? That's absolutely right, yeah. Franz Joseph, you know, the Habsburgs are not quite what they were, but Franz Joseph still rules this sort of great patchwork of Central Europe, including a bit of Northern Italy.
哦，真的吗？我永远也猜不到。是的，但不同之处在于，好吧，我们会探讨一些不同之处，但是是的，所以为了把这一切放在背景中，嗯，马克西米利安出生于1832年，我想是的，比弗朗茨·约瑟夫小两岁。大概是这样吗？完全正确，是的。弗朗茨·约瑟夫，你知道的，哈布斯堡家族已经今非昔比了，但弗朗茨·约瑟夫仍然统治着这个庞大的中欧拼凑而成的国家，其中还包括一小部分意大利北部。
And meanwhile, so Mexico, I suppose, and the Spanish Empire had once been a Habsburg possession, but obviously that's a long time in the past. And what's going on in Mexico? I mean, why on earth would an Austrian end up in Mexico, Ed? That's an excellent question. So to take us to Mexico, it becomes independent, unlike most other Latin American nations, as a monarchy. The Spanish royalist changes sides, joins the independence movement, fights against the Spaniards and manages to unite the disparate forces fighting against Spain. Now he does that with this plan, which is that Mexico should become a monarchy ruled by a member of the Spanish royal family. The Spanish King Ferdinand VII, who I think has got to be one of the most incompetent monarchs of the 19th century, and that's a highly competitive field, refuses point blank to accept this plan whatsoever. So you're presented with a problem. You have a monarchy, but you don't have a monarch. Itabide, the Spanish royalist officer who's changed sides, his solution is he crowns
与此同时，墨西哥，我想，西班牙帝国曾一度是哈布斯堡王朝的领地，但那显然已经是遥远的过去了。墨西哥正在发生什么？我的意思是，一个奥地利人怎么会落脚墨西哥呢，埃德？这是一个极好的问题。为了带我们了解墨西哥，它像大多数其他拉丁美洲国家一样独立了，但作为一个君主国。西班牙保王党人改变了立场，加入了独立运动，与西班牙人作战，并成功团结了反抗西班牙的各方力量。现在他是通过这个计划做到这一点的，即墨西哥应该成为一个由西班牙皇室成员统治的君主国。西班牙国王斐迪南七世（Ferdinand VII），我认为他绝对是19世纪最无能的君主之一，而这是一个竞争非常激烈的领域，他斩钉截铁地拒绝接受这个计划。所以你面临着一个问题。你有一个君主国，却没有君主。伊图尔维德（Iturbide），那个改变了立场的西班牙保王党军官，他的解决办法就是为自己
himself emperor. So Mexico does become an empire. There's a first Mexican empire, but it's disastrous. His reign is short, nine months. He's very quickly deposed, goes off into exile, actually comes back in 1824, expecting to be welcomed as a hero. He's not. He's arrested and then executed for treason. So that's the first emperor of independent Mexico. Now, after that, Mexico is plagued by instability. It does become a republic, but violence much more important than the ballot box in determining who holds power. And if you want to sys-espean task, try and memorize every single Mexican president from 1824 to 1861. If you include the interim presidents and the presidents who are not recognized by other presidents, it's near impossible. So you have what we might call anachronistically a failed state in
加冕为皇帝。因此墨西哥确实成为了一个帝国。这就是墨西哥第一帝国，但它是灾难性的。他的统治很短，只有九个月。他很快就被废黜，流亡海外，实际上在1824年又回来了，本以为会受到英雄般的欢迎。但他没有。他被捕了，然后因叛国罪被处决。这就是独立墨西哥的第一位皇帝。此后，墨西哥便饱受动荡之苦。它确实变成了一个共和国，但在决定谁掌握权力方面，暴力远比选票更为重要。如果你想完成一项西西弗斯式的任务，那就去试着记住1824年到1861年间的每一位墨西哥总统吧。如果算上临时总统以及不被其他总统承认的总统，那几乎是不可能的。所以你拥有了一个我们在拉丁美洲可以不合时宜地称之为失败国家的实体。
Latin America. But so far, apart from that beginning with monarchy, not that different to the fate of many other Latin American republics. What also sets Mexico apart is its proximity to the United States of America. And as a later president of Mexico famously says, poor Mexico, so far from God, so close to the United States. And nowhere would that have been more apparent than in 1846. United States of America declares war on Mexico. It's a nakedly expansionist drive to dominate the North American continent. In just over a year, US troops march up from Veracruz,
但到目前为止，除了以君主制开端这一点外，它与其他许多拉丁美洲共和国的命运并没有太大区别。让墨西哥与众不同的还有它与美洲合众国的邻近性。正如后来一位墨西哥总统的名言：“可怜的墨西哥，离上帝太远，离美国太近。”1846年，这一点表现得再明显不过了。美洲合众国对墨西哥宣战。这是一场赤裸裸的扩张主义驱使，旨在统治北美大陆。在短短一年多一点的时间里，美军从贝拉克鲁斯——
the main Atlantic port of Mexico, and occupy the magnificent city, the capital of Mexico City, unfurling the stars and stripes across this glorious main square with the Catholic cathedral looming over them. Now, they only leave at an extraordinary high price. The Mexican government gets $15 million, which was nothing then, bearing in mind that what the United States of America is going to get, they're going to get half of Mexico's national territory. So this is places today like California, for example. And in return, US troops will end the occupation and a peace treaty is signed. So you not only do you have political instability, you have national humiliation and trauma. And in the 1850s, things don't improve. There's a civil war between two rival
墨西哥主要的太平洋（原文如此，实为大西洋）港口——一路北上，占领了那座宏伟的城市，即墨西哥首都墨西哥城，并在荣耀的主广场上展开了星条旗，天主教大教堂在他们头顶巍然耸立。现在，他们只有在付出极其高昂的代价后才会离开。墨西哥政府得到了1500万美元，考虑到美国即将获得的土地，这在当时根本不算什么，他们将获得墨西哥一半的领土。所以这些地方今天就是比如加利福尼亚。作为回报，美军将结束占领，并签署和平条约。所以你不仅面临政治动荡，还经历了民族羞辱和创伤。到了19世纪50年代，情况并没有改善。两个敌对派别之间爆发了内战，
factions, very loose political parties, liberals and conservatives. The liberals are led by Benito Juarez, and their argument as to why Mexico is in the situation it is, is that it's not liberal enough, it's not secular enough. And Ed, Juarez is actually, he's indigenous, isn't he? So he's not of Spanish descent. Yes, he's from indigenous peoples of Mexico, Zapotec, just outside of Oaxaca, which is southeast Mexico. He comes from an incredibly humble background.
这是非常松散的政党，自由派和保守派。自由派由贝尼托·华雷斯（Benito Juarez）领导，他们对墨西哥目前处境的解释是，它不够自由，不够世俗。埃德，华雷斯实际上是原住民，对吧？所以他不是西班牙血统。是的，他来自墨西哥的原住民萨波特克人（Zapotec），就在瓦哈卡（Oaxaca）郊外，也就是墨西哥东南部。他出身于极其卑微的背景。
Oh, absolutely. He's an extraordinary figure. And as we'll see throughout this story, he's someone who stays with it for the whole duration and, of course, stays with it for longer than Maximilian in the end. He's an extraordinary figure, determined on self-improvement. So if you read his sort of own notes, his own kind of autobiographical notes, he talks about how he wanted to learn Spanish, because Spanish wasn't his first language in this indigenous community that he grew up in, in foothills and mountains, very desolate. So he wanted to learn Spanish to better himself, and
哦，绝对是的。他是一个非凡的人物。正如我们在整个故事中所看到的，他是一个坚持到底的人，当然到头来他坚持的时间比马克西米利安还要长。他是一个非凡的人物，决心自我完善。因此，如果你阅读他的那种笔记，他自己的自传性笔记，他会谈到他是如何想要学习西班牙语的，因为在他成长的这个位于山麓和山脉、非常荒凉的原住民社区里，西班牙语不是他的第一语言。所以他想学西班牙语来充实自己，
his uncle was one of the few people who spoke Spanish. So sort of after toiling all day in the field, he would go to his uncle's house, And he wasn't making sufficient progress in his studies. So he used to take a whip, and he would ask his uncle to beat him to improve his Spanish. Tougher than Duolingo, isn't it? It's very Gladstonean behaviour. So you've got this extraordinarily determined individual in Benito Juarez, and he comes to power. Well, it's not him in power in 1855, but it's his party and it's a group of much more radical liberals determined to break the power of the Catholic Church, which is not only has an enormous spiritual hold over Mexico, but is the biggest landowner, is the principal economic powerhouse.
而他的叔叔是少数几个会说西班牙语的人之一。因此，在田里辛劳了一整天之后，他会去他叔叔的家，而他的学习进展不够快。所以他以前会拿一根鞭子，要求他的叔叔抽打他，以此来提高他的西班牙语水平。比多邻国（Duolingo）还要残酷，不是吗？这是一种非常格莱斯顿式的行为。所以你有了贝尼托·华雷斯这样一个极其坚定的个人，他掌权了。好吧，1855年掌权的不是他，而是他的政党，是一群更加激进的自由派，决心打破天主教教会的权力，天主教会在墨西哥不仅拥有巨大的精神控制力，而且是最大的土地所有者，是主要的经济动力源泉。
And so the key reform here is they nationalize church property and sell it on the open market as any good liberal will, which has two happy effects of that. One, you break the power of the Catholic Church and two, you enrich the coffers of the government treasury. Now, for the other faction, the conservatives, the reason why Mexico has been humiliated and is politically unstable is not because it's not liberal enough, but because it's gone too far in that direction. And the only thing they argue that meaningfully binds Mexico together as a nation state is Catholicism. So you have a bitter divide over the future of Mexico. Long story short, Benito Juarez's liberals win. They enter the capital in triumph in 1861. Conservatives are defeated and they flee, many of them in exile.
因此，这里的关键改革是他们将教会财产国有化，并在公开市场上出售，就像任何优秀的自由派所做的那样，这产生了两个令人高兴的效果。第一，你打破了天主教教会的权力；第二，你充盈了政府国库的金库。现在，对于另一派——保守派来说，墨西哥之所以受到羞辱并陷入政治动荡，不是因为它不够自由，而是因为它在这条路上走得太远了。他们认为，作为民族国家能够有意义地将墨西哥凝聚在一起的唯一东西就是天主教。因此，对于墨西哥的未来，你们存在着深刻的分歧。长话短说，贝尼托·华雷斯的自由派获胜了。他们在1861年凯旋进入首都。保守派战败并逃亡，其中许多人流亡海外。
Benito Juarez holds elections and becomes the constitutional president of Mexico. But those exiles never accept, and actually many conservatives still in Mexico, never accept that result. Shock, horror. Who would have thought that? I know, disgraceful behavior in the 19th century. So to put this into context, Ed, you just said 1861. So 1861 is the year of the outbreak of the American Civil War. So at this point, the big sort of bullying neighbor to the north is absorbed by its own problems, because of course, actually now, to the north of Mexico, it's the Confederate States of America fighting the Civil War against the Union. Now, the other issue, I guess, is, am I right in thinking that the major
贝尼托·华雷斯举行选举，成为墨西哥的宪政总统。但那些流亡者从未接受——实际上墨西哥国内的许多保守派也从未接受——那个结果。震惊，恐惧。谁能想到这一点？我懂的，这是19世纪极其耻辱的行为。为了把这放在历史背景中，埃德，你刚才说的是1861年。所以1861年是美国内战爆发的那一年。因此，在这一点上，北方那个大个子、霸道的邻居正被自身的麻烦所吞噬，因为当然，实际上现在在墨西哥的北方，是美利坚联盟国（Confederate States of America）在与联邦（Union）进行内战。现在，另一个问题，我想，我没想错的话，墨西哥面临的主要
problem for Mexico is indebtedness? It's a problem of so many countries in what we would now call the developing world in the 19th century. They've run up colossal debts to Europe, largely to European sort of lenders, haven't they? They have. And the Mexican government particularly took out a series of loans in the 1820s, which they never paid back. And the principal debtor to the nation to whom they owe the debt is actually Britain. But they have also money which they owe to France and which they owe to Spain. Now, given the political history of Mexico, given the US-Mexican war and the civil war that we've just described, the treasury is not overflowing. You won't be surprised to hear. So what Benito Juarez
问题是债务吗？这是19世纪我们现在所说的发展中国家许多国家都存在的问题。他们背上了对欧洲的巨额债务，主要是对欧洲那种贷款人的债务，不是吗？是的。墨西哥政府在20世纪（原文如此，应为19世纪）20年代特别借了一系列从未偿还的贷款。他们欠债的主要国家实际上是英国。但他们也欠法国和西班牙钱。鉴于墨西哥的政治历史，鉴于美墨战争以及我们刚刚描述的内战，国库并没有盈余。听到这个你不会感到惊讶。所以贝尼托·华雷斯作为一项紧急措施所做的是，他暂停了对外债务的支付。他要求——好吧，他不是要求，他宣布了，国会宣布两年不支付外债。现在，在19世纪中叶，这种行为会招致欧洲大国相当迅速的回应，那就是军事干预。
does as an emergency measure is he suspends foreign debt payment. He asks, well, he doesn't ask, he declares it, and Congress declares two years without paying foreign debt. Now, in the mid 19th century, that kind of behaviour has a pretty quick response from European powers, which is military intervention. Right. So we have, on the one hand, a man of peasant background, indigenous, didn't even learn to speak Spanish, hauled himself up from his bootstraps, who's become president of a liberal but massively indebted Mexican republic. On the other hand, we've already introduced him, Maximilian the Archduke, one of the long line of Habsburgs, one of the probably the most famous royal dynasty in the whole of Europe. Now, the person who brings them together, who joins, who binds their fates
没错。所以我们一方面看到的是一个农民出身、原住民、甚至没有学过说西班牙语、白手起家成为一个自由派但背负巨额债务的墨西哥共和国总统的人；另一方面，我们已经介绍过他了，大公马克西米利安，长长的哈布斯堡家族的一员，可以说是整个欧洲最著名的皇室王朝之一。现在，这个把他们联系在一起，将他们的命运结合在一起的人——我想我们可以称之为本期播客的反派，汤姆。他会不会恰好是个法国人？他是。他是个法国人。在某些方面是典型的法国人，在其他方面则不然。这就是拿破仑三世，更有名的拿破仑的侄子，也是一个同样——我们故事里有好几个这样的人——坚信自己命运的人。拿破仑三世坚信他是那个将带领法国重回伟大，更重要的是让自己走向伟大，并以某种形式恢复他叔叔的帝国的人，他确实在19世纪30年代和40年代经历了数次失败的尝试后成功做到了这一点。他实际上是法国历史上第一位民选总统，恰好是一个波拿巴，路易-拿破仑·波拿巴。我应该指出，这种情况下是成年男性普选。他面临的问题是，法兰西第二共和国——他现在担任总统的政权——有一部宪法，禁止他连任。
together. I think we can say the villain of this podcast, Tom. Would he be, by any chance, a Frenchman? He is. He is a Frenchman. In some ways, a quintessential Frenchman, in other ways not. This is Napoleon III, nephew of the more famous Napoleon, and a man, similarly, we've got quite a few people in the story convinced of their destiny. Napoleon III is convinced that he is the man who will lead France back to greatness and, more importantly, lead himself to greatness and restore his uncle's empire in some form, which he does manage to do despite several failed attempts in the 1830s and 1840s. He's actually the first ever democratically elected president of France, happens to be a Bonaparte, Louis-Napoleon Bonaparte. I should say it's universal male suffrage in this case. The problem he has is that the Second Republic, the regime that he is now president of, has a constitution which prohibits him being re-elected.
所以他做了任何一个有自尊心的波拿巴主义者会做的事：对自己的政府发动了政变，一年后，即1852年，宣布自己为法兰西皇帝。是的，这太拿破仑了。所以可以想见，他是在自觉地追随他叔叔的脚步。我想他每天醒来都会问自己，我叔叔会怎么做？然后试图做某种版本的尝试。但关于1851年他发动政变的那一刻，同样重要的是，他在那里所做的是他摧毁了一个共和国。并在那个共和国的废墟上创造了一个帝国，一个君主制。这就是卡尔·马克思那句名言的来源。第一次是悲剧，第二次是闹剧。如果人们听说过拿破仑三世，通常是通过卡尔·马克思关于那场政变的引言。但在19世纪50年代，他的政权几乎没有一点闹剧的成分。事实上，经济蓬勃发展，外交政策取得了成功。他与英国结盟参加克里米亚战争。他们在1859年入侵意大利北部，击败了弗朗茨·约瑟夫。似乎他已经结束了法国的孤立，在某种程度上恢复了法国的伟大，并建立了一个国内稳定的政治体系。所以这是墨西哥的君主主义者和保守派所关注的事情。他们通过拿破仑三世的妻子欧仁妮皇后（Empress Eugenie）吹风。他们向他推销的构想是“让墨西哥再次伟大”，借用一句名言。你需要回归独立的最初理念，那就是君主制。所以他们
So he does what any self-respecting Bonapartist would do, launches a coup d'etat against his own government, and a year later, in 1852, declares himself emperor of the French. Yeah, that's so Napoleonic. And so presumably he is self-consciously following in the footsteps of his uncle. I think he wakes up every day and asks himself, what would my uncle have done? And tries to do some kind of version of it. But what's important as well about that moment in 1851, where he launches the coup d'etat, is that what he has done there is he has destroyed a republic. And on the ashes of that republic created an empire, a monarchy. This is where the famous Karl Marx quote comes. The first time is tragedy. The second time is farce. If people have heard of Napoleon III, it's often through that Karl Marx quote talking about
所以他做了任何一个有自尊心的波拿巴主义者都会做的事：对自己的政府发动政变，一年后的1852年，他宣布自己为法兰西皇帝。是的，这太拿破仑了。所以据推测，他是有意识地追随他叔叔的脚步。我想他每天醒来都会问自己，我叔叔会怎么做？并试图做某种版本的事情。但1851年他发动政变的那一刻同样重要的是，他在那里所做的是摧毁了一个共和国。并在那个共和国的废墟上建立了一个帝国，一个君主国。这就是卡尔·马克思名言的由来。第一次是悲剧，第二次是闹剧。如果人们听说过拿破仑三世，往往是通过卡尔·马克思关于……的引言
the coup. But in the 1850s, there's not very much farce at all about his regime. In fact, the economy booms, the foreign policy is a success. He allies with Britain in fighting the Crimean War. They invade northern Italy in 1859, defeating Franz Joseph. And it seems as though he's ended France's isolation, restored France to greatness to some extent, and has created a domestically stable political system. So this is something that monarchists and conservatives in Mexico take a look at. And they have the ear of Napoleon III through his wife, the Empress Eugenie. Their pitch to him is to make Mexico great again, to coin a phrase. You need to return to the original idea of independence, which is monarchy. And so they
告诉拿破仑三世，这将是极其容易的。我们只需要几千名法军。我们出现在那里。我们将宣布这项计划，即将墨西哥恢复到最初的君主制状态。被华雷斯击败的墨西哥保守派将蜂拥聚集到这面旗帜下。而贝尼托·华雷斯，你可能会说他是个自由派，实际上，他是个暴君。这是一个压迫墨西哥沉默大多数的激进少数派，一旦马克西米利安出现，他们就会欢呼他为皇帝。好吧，拿破仑。现在，这对他有什么好处呢？因为很显然，法国，你知道，它在拉丁美洲——我们现在所认为的拉丁美洲、南美洲、中美洲或北美洲的底部——并不是一个伟大的殖民强权，他在想他能开辟一个新的法属美洲帝国吗？还是他冲着自然资源来的？他只是想让别人还债吗？还是仅仅为了声誉？究竟是什么？他认为他会得到什么？
tell Napoleon III it's going to be incredibly easy. All we would need is a few thousand French troops. We'll turn up there. We'll declare the plan, which is to restore Mexico to its original state of monarchy. Mexican conservatives who have been defeated by Juarez will flock to the banner. And Benito Juarez, you may say he's a liberal, actually, he's a despot. It's a radical minority oppressing the silent majority of Mexicans who will, once Maximilian turns up, acclaim him as emperor. Right, Napoleon. Now, what's in it for him? Because obviously, France, you know, it hasn't been a great colonial power in latin what we now think of as latin america and south america central america or the bottom bit of north america is he thinking he can he can carve
实际上，这是所有这些因素的混合。但我认为这里值得指出的一点是，他对拉丁美洲确实有着极其宏大的构想。嗯，他创造了这个词，不是吗？他并没有创造这个词，但这个词最早是在19世纪50年代的巴黎被创造出来的。关于谁在什么时候说了什么，有一些争议。但那是19世纪50年代中期。正是在巴黎，拉丁美洲这个概念浮出水面并开始被表达出来。
out a new a new french american empire or is he after the natural resources does he just want his debts paid or is it just about press what is it what what's what does he think he's going to get it's a mixture of all of those things, in fact. But I think one thing that's interesting to flag here is he does have incredibly grand vision for Latin America. Well, he comes up with the term, doesn't he? He doesn't come up with the term, but the term is first coined in Paris in the 1850s. And there's a bit of dispute about who said what and when. But it's mid-1850s. It's in Paris where this idea of Latin America bubbles up and begins to get expressed.
对拉丁美洲的一种愿景，也是拿破仑三世所赞同的一种愿景，就是这种观点：具有天主教传统和文化的南方国家，与南欧天主教国家有着亲缘关系。当然，最强大的南欧天主教国家就是法国。所以拉丁美洲，而且，那个词“拉丁”是与盎格鲁-撒克逊、北方的美洲合众国相对立的，对吧？
One vision of Latin America, which is one that Napoleon III is sympathetic to, is this idea of Southern countries with a Catholic tradition and culture have an affinity with the Southern European Catholic countries. And of course, the most powerful Southern European Catholic country is France. So Latin America, and it's, it's that term Latin is in opposition to Anglo-Saxon, Northern United States of America, right? And
而它之所以在19世纪50年代被创造出来，是因为你要划定一个法国的影响力范围，以对抗进一步的美国侵略，因为19世纪50年代没有人认为美国的扩张会在它停下的地方停止。但美国已经颁布了门罗主义，不是吗？所以他们基本上已经说过，美国已经公开表示他们不希望欧洲列强再卷入西半球事务了。但拿破仑仍然认为他可以蒙混过关。他认为，管他妈的美国。他们有他们自己的奴隶制麻烦。
the reason why it becomes, it becomes coined in the 1850s is because you're demarcating an area of influence for France that is in opposition to further US aggression, because no one in the 1850s thinks that US expansion is going to stop where it stops. But the US have proclaimed the Monroe Doctrine, though, haven't they? So they basically said, the US have publicly said they don't want European powers involved in the Western hemisphere anymore. But Napoleon still thinks he can get away with it. He thinks, kind of sod the US. They've got their own troubles about slavery.
我可以直接忽视他们。基本上是这样吗，我的意思是，还是我太简单化了？不，一点也不。正因为美国内战，拿破仑三世才得以尝试将他的愿景付诸实践。因为被联邦和邦联之间的冲突撕裂，门罗主义——实际上极其受欢迎，而且是外交政策的民族主义基石——不仅在权力走廊里被讨论，它还是一个你可以站上去在选举中谈论并赢得人们欢呼的话题。他们不敢害怕，或者说不敢冒险去激怒法国，把法国卷入内战，潜在地承认邦联，更糟糕的是提供某种调解，甚至可能直接进行军事干预。所以，有趣的是，林肯在1861年至1865年间甚至没有使用过一次“门罗主义”这个词。嗯，因为在你的书中，你把这个插曲描述为门罗主义自古巴导弹危机以来所面临的最大挑战，你知道的，我的意思是，这相当了不起。它让你感受到了其中涉及的地缘政治利害关系，在一个可能看起来几乎像是滑稽歌剧（opera bouffe）般的插曲中，但我完全同意，我坚持这一观点，这次法国的干预——君主制、天主教，就在美洲合众国的边境上。我的意思是，这就是每个人都……哈布斯堡家族。哈布斯堡家族出现在你家门口。我的意思是，这就是人们……太恐怖了。所以你说，汤姆说哈布斯堡家族。拿破仑需要一个候选人。他没想到要挑选……我的意思是，我告诉你他叔叔会怎么做，埃德。他叔叔会从他自己的家族里挑一个。
I can just ignore them. Is that basically, I mean, or am I being too simplistic? No, not at all. And it's precisely because of the US Civil War that Napoleon III is able to try and put his vision into practice. Because torn apart with the conflict between Union and Confederacy, the Monroe Doctrine, which is incredibly popular, actually, and that sort of nationalist cornerstone of foreign policy, it's not just in the corridors of power where it's discussed, it's something that
为什么拿破仑不这么做？当然。而且他有很多。有大量的波拿巴家族成员闲置着。这也是他们不断卷土重来的部分原因。所以我认为，即使对于一个像拿破仑三世那样痴迷于波拿巴神话的人来说，他也觉得这是他绝不应该效仿他叔叔的一个政策领域。这也是一种感觉，因为他正试图，
you can get up on and talk about in elections and people cheer. They cannot fear, they cannot risk, rather, antagonising the French and getting the French involved into the civil war, potentially recognising the Confederacy, worse still, offering some kind of mediation or perhaps even getting involved militarily. So the Monroe Doctrine, interestingly, Lincoln doesn't use the phrase Monroe Doctrine once from 1861 to 1865. Well, because in your book, you describe this episode as the greatest challenge to the Monroe Doct until the cuban missile crisis which is you know i mean that's quite something it's it gives you a sense of the kind of geopolitical stakes that were involved in in what might seem a you know an almost kind of opera buffet kind of episode but i i completely agree and i stand by that and this is this this
而且当我们进入他所创造的事物时就会看到这一点，墨西哥的独立是这个构想的核心。现在，究竟有没有独立，这是我们稍后可以讨论的事情，但让一个同父异母的兄弟或表亲之类的人坐在墨西哥的王位上，并不是一个很有力的形象。所以这对他来说不是一个选项。波拿巴家族与法国王室的关系当然并不辉煌。所以你不能找一个法国君主。一些极右翼的墨西哥保守派可能不介意一个西班牙君主，但即使以他们有限的眼光，他们也意识到西班牙殖民主义带来的有毒遗产是
french intervention monarchy catholicism on the borders of the United States of America. I mean, this is the very nightmare that everyone's sort of... Habsburgs. Habsburgs turning up on your doorstep. I mean, this is what people... The horror. So you say, Tom says Habsburgs. Napoleon needs a candidate. He doesn't think of picking... I mean, I tell you what his uncle would have done, Ed. His uncle would have picked one of his family.
很难推销的。而且，如果你在19世纪寻找一位君主，哈布斯堡这个名字是出类拔萃、凌驾于所有其他人之上的耀眼名字。所以，如果你能把一个哈布斯堡家族的人拉上船，对这个项目来说将是梦幻般的。当然，这也与16世纪有着联系，正是在查理五世皇帝——同时也是西班牙国王——统治下，墨西哥才首次被征服并置于西班牙帝国的统治之下。所以你也有那份历史遗产。而且并不是要简化问题，但马克西米利安看起来也很像个皇帝，对吧？我的意思是，他是一个身材高大、外表威严、留着分叉胡须的人。我的意思是，很显然，整个事情的外在形象将是非常重要的。
Why doesn't Napoleon do that? Of course. And he's got plenty. There are loads of Bonapartes lying around. That's part of the reason why they keep coming back. So I think even for a man as self-obsessed with the Bonapartist myth as Napoleon III, he feels that that's one sort of area of policy in which he shouldn't emulate his uncle. And it's also a sense because he's trying to,
我的意思是，整个概念中带有烟雾弹和镜子的轻微成分。这确实是，而且当然，这是君主制的重要组成部分，实际上也是马克西米利安生活的重要组成部分。我的意思是，他痴迷于细节和礼仪的微末之处，但也痴迷于君主制的外部表象。所以，是的，绝对的。他很适合这个角色。另一个原因是他有空，因为正如我们之前所说，他被他的兄弟弗朗茨·约瑟夫边缘化了。如果我们要把他和哈里联系起来的话，
and we'll see this when we get into what he creates, the independence of Mexico is central to the idea. Now, whether there is any independence or not, something we can discuss later, but having a half-brother or a cousin or whatever on the throne of Mexico is not a strong look. So that's not an option for him. Bonaparte's relations with the French royal houses is, of course, not brilliant. So you can't have a French monarch. And some of the sort of ultra-conservative Mexicans wouldn't mind a Spanish monarch, but even with their limited horizons, they're aware that the sort of toxic legacy of Spanish colonialism is
那么——谁是梅根？每个哈里都需要他们的梅根。所以马克西米利安的梅根登场了。她就是夏洛特公主。现在，她在墨西哥历史上更广为人知的名字是卡尔洛塔（Carlotta）。她是比利时国王利奥波德一世的女儿，母亲一方与法国国王和王后有亲戚关系。所以她拥有——为了把梅根的类比推得更远——由于身为比利时公主，她并不是一个
that's a hard sell. But also, if you're looking for a monarch in the 19th century, the name Habsburg is the illustrious one that sort of stands out above all others. And so if you could get a Habsburg on board, That would be fantastic for the project. And of course, the connection as well with the 16th century, it's under Emperor Charles V, also king of Spain, that Mexico is first subjugated and brought under the Spanish Empire. So you have that legacy as well. And not to be reductive, but also Maximilian looks like an emperor, right? I mean, he's a tall, impressive looking guy with a forked beard. I mean, but obviously the look of the whole business is going to be very important.
与哈布斯堡家族平起平坐的人。现在，马克西米利安被派去执行他兄弟喜欢让他去执行的各种无意义的外交使命之一，因为这能把他弄出奥地利，远离权力中心。他对去比利时宫廷感到非常不屑。他认为像他这样的人竟然不得不去一个1831年（也就是他出生前一年）才建立的君主国，这简直令人作呕，所以他很难认真对待它。当他在那里时，他去参加了其中一个舞会，他说这太糟糕了，因为（你知道的）国家的精英们竟然与他们的裁缝和鞋匠混在一起并交谈，这是不应该被允许发生的事情。不过，他确实喜欢的一件事是夏洛特公主卡尔洛塔。你知道吗，我一点也不觉得奇怪，因为，多米尼克，你有没有注意到，她12岁时最喜欢的科目是什么？提醒我一下，汤姆。宗教和普鲁塔克。哦，天哪。真是个女孩。真是个女孩。多么噩梦般的形象。我二话不说就会娶她。而这正是马克西米利安的想法，事实上他随后也这么做了。几个月内，他们就结婚了。
I mean, it's a slight element of smoke and mirrors about the whole concept. Which is and which, of course, is a huge part of monarchy and indeed a huge part of Maximilian's life. I mean, he's obsessed with the minutiae of detail and etiquette, but also the outward appearance of monarchy. And so, yeah, absolutely. He fits the role. And the other reason is that he's available because as we said earlier, he's been sidelined by his brother, Franz Joseph. And if we are going to make the Harry connection,
而她本身也是个极其有野心的人。但很显然，作为19世纪的贵族女性，她需要一个丈夫来扮演有意义的政治角色。她有一种使命感，不是吗？就像这个故事里的每个人一样。每个人都有使命感。上帝挑选她是为了某种未明确的目的。是这样吗？
then- Who is Meghan? Every Harry needs their Meghan. And so enter Maximilian's Meghan. She's Princess Charlotte. Now, she's better known to Mexican history as Carlotta. But she's the daughter of the Belgian king, Leopold I, and her mother's side related to the kings and queens of France. So she has, and to push the Meghan analogy further, by virtue of being a Belgian princess, she's not someone who is on
她极其虔诚，极其信仰天主教。是的，并且非常笃信普罗维デンス（providence，天意）这个她总是挂在嘴边的词。而其中的一个条件是，利奥波德一世同意这一安排的前提是弗朗茨·约瑟夫给予马克西米利安一个权力职位，一个有意义的权力职位。那就是伦巴第-威尼斯总督，这是当时奥地利帝国意大利北部最富裕的地区之一。但这是一只烫手山芋，因为意大利民族主义的力量使得任何人都很难把这份工作做好并取得成功。所以这非常像是，“哦，你想要一个权力职位。好吧，给你，试试这个吧。”即便如此，弗朗茨·约瑟夫还是相当小心地将真正的权力留在维也纳，让它远离马克西米利安。两年内，拿破仑三世——他对意大利民族主义有着一种年轻的、浪漫的热爱——支持皮埃蒙特，带着20万军队入侵意大利北部，并在意大利北部击败了弗朗茨·约瑟夫。弗朗茨·约瑟夫在几周前还以非常羞辱的方式解除了马克西米利安的职务。所以，到19世纪50年代末和1860年代初，你所拥有的是马克西米利安和卡尔洛塔，他们大材小用、不被赏识，但两人都坚信自己有着更伟大的命运。所以为了把这一点，
an equal footing with the Habsburgs. Now, Maximilian has been sent on one of these sort of various pointless diplomatic missions that his brother likes to get him on because it gets him out of Austria and away from the centre of power. And he's very dismissive of going to the Belgian court. He thinks it's disgusting that someone like him should have to go to a monarchy which was only created in 1831, you know, a year before he was born. So it's hard for him to take it seriously. And when he's there, he goes to one of these bulls and he says it's awful because, you know, the elite of the country are sort of mixing and talking
为了彻底敲定这一点，他们从来没有去过墨西哥。从来没有。他们从来没有去过墨西哥。他们不会说西班牙语。好吧。此时还不会。不，说得不流利，说得不流利。所以他们不是流利的西班牙语使用者。
with their tailors and their cobblers, and it's the kind of thing that shouldn't be allowed to happen. One thing he does like, though, is Princess Charlotte Carlotta. Well, do you know, I'm not surprised because, Dominic, did you pick up on this, that her favourite subjects when she was age 12? Remind me, Tom. Religion and Plutarch. Oh, my God. What a girl. What a girl. What a nightmarish image. I'd marry her like a shot. Which is exactly what Maximilian thinks, and indeed then does. Within months, they're married.
他们从未横渡过大西洋。马克西米利安其实去过。他去过巴西。是的。在他被解除伦巴第-威尼斯总督职务后，马克西米利安喜欢旅行。那种漫游癖，
And she's fiercely ambitious herself. But obviously, as an aristocratic woman in the 19th century, she needs a husband for a meaningful political role. And she has a sense of destiny, doesn't she? Like everybody on this story. Everyone has a sense of destiny. God has picked her for some unspecified purpose. Is that right?
到异国他乡去环游世界。亚历山大·冯·洪堡式的人物是他的伟大偶像之一。但他没有去过北美，对吧？不，他没有。巴西离墨西哥非常遥远。我去过巴西餐厅，但这并不意味着我能胜任巴西的统治。你去过墨西哥吗？好吧，没有，不过我去过巴西。
She's incredibly pious and incredibly Catholic. And yes, and very much buys into that vision of providence is the word that she always uses. And part of the condition, the Leopold I agrees to it on the proviso that Franz Joseph gives Maximilian a position of power, a meaningful position of power. And that is governor of Lombardy, Venetia, which is one of the richest parts of the Austrian empire at this time in Northern Italy. But it's a poison chalice because the forces of Italian nationalism make this an incredibly difficult job for anyone to do well and succeed in. So it's very much, oh, you wanted a position of power. Well, here you go, try this. Even then, Franz Joseph was quite careful to keep real power in Vienna and away from Maximilian. And within two years, Napoleon III, who had a sort of youthful, romantic love of Italian nationalism, backs Piedmont, invades northern Italy with 200,000
是的，这就是他的推销说辞。所以——所以这显然对他们来说是个绝妙的主意。这确实看起来像个绝妙的主意。确实。所以基本上他同意了。卡尔洛塔同意了，他们决定他们会去。他们接受了这个。我想我们此时应该休息一下，当我们回来时，我们应该——看看马克西米利安和卡尔洛塔扬帆驶向他们的王国时究竟发生了什么的故事。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，
troops and defeats Franz Joseph in northern Italy. Franz Joseph has, sort of weeks before, sacked Maximilian as well, very humiliatingly. So what you have by the end of the 1850s and certainly beginning of the 1860s is you have Maximilian and Carlotta who are underemployed, underappreciated, but both convinced that they have a much greater destiny. So just to put this into,
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前获得现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。汤姆，好消息。
just to absolutely nail this down, they have never been to Mexico. Never. They don never been to Mexico. Never. They don't speak Spanish. Well. Not at this point. No, not fluently, not fluently. So they don't fluently Spanish speakers.
赞助商 UnHerd，即 U-N-H-E-R-D，这家在线杂志致力于打破群体思维并鼓励独立思考。他们回归了。太棒了。这真是个好消息，不是吗？这真是太棒了。多米尼克，他们即将出版什么内容？好吧，汤姆，我讨厌自吹自擂。
They've never crossed the Atlantic. Maximilian has actually. He's been to Brazil. Yeah. After he gets sacked as governor of Lombardy, Venetia, Maximilian loves to travel. That's sort of of wanderlust,
其实我并不讨厌。我简直爱死它了。所以刚为他们写了一篇文章，其实是他们的主意。那是雅各布·法拉第（Jacob Faraday）的主意，他是 Unheard 的编辑之一。他说这是75周年纪念日，我想是在3月12日，
travelling the globe to the exotic. Alexander von Humboldt-esque is one of his great heroes. But he's not been to North America, right? No, he's not. Brazil is a very long way away from Mexico. I've been to a Brazilian restaurant, but I wouldn't supply it to become Brazil. Have you been to Mexico? Well, no, I have been to Brazil, though.
关于杜鲁门主义的颁布。你知道那是什么吗，杜鲁门主义？不知道。好吧，那我来告诉你。这就是为什么你必须阅读 Unheard，汤姆。是的。所以哈里·杜鲁门，个子不高、来自堪萨斯城的原男服饰品零售商，在两年后一跃成为1945年的美国总统。那是罗斯福去世的时候。当罗斯福去世时。然后是第二次世界大战结束和冷战开始时那种混乱的时期。接着在1947年，
Yeah, that's his pitch. So so so obviously it's a brilliant idea to them. It does seem like a brilliant idea. It does. And so basically he signs up to it. Carlotta signs up to it and they decide that they they will go. They accept this. I think we should take a break at this point uh and when we come back we should um look at the story of of what actually happens when maximilian and carlotta set sail for their kingdom i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A,
他在国会联席会议前发表讲话，基本上表示，我们正与苏联处于全球冲突中。我们要给希腊和土耳其提供大量资金来遏制共产主义。我们不能允许他们强推共产主义。然后基本上我们有了一项新政策，那就是无论共产主义在哪里，都要遏制它。
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Tom, excellent news.
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、专属加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。汤姆，好消息。
Sponsors UnHerd, that's U-N-H-E-R-D, the online magazine that pushes back against herd mentality and encourages independent thinking. They are back. Hooray. It's great news, isn't it? That's fantastic news. And what are they publishing imminently, Dominic? Well, Tom, I hate to blow my own trumpet.
赞助商 UnHerd（即 U-N-H-E-R-D），这家网络杂志旨在打破盲从心理并鼓励独立思考。他们回归了。太好了。这真是个好消息，不是吗？太棒了。多米尼克，他们即将发表什么内容？好吧，汤姆，我讨厌自吹自擂。
I don't, actually. I don't hate it at all. I love it. So I have just written a piece for them about, it was their idea, actually. It was Jacob Faraday's idea, one of the editors at Unheard. And he said this was the 75th anniversary, on I think March the 12th,
其实我并不讨厌。我一点也不讨厌，我喜欢得很。所以我刚为他们写了一篇文章，其实这也是他们的主意。这是 Unheard 的编辑之一雅各布·法拉第（Jacob Faraday）的主意。他说这是75周年纪念，我想是在3月12日左右，
of the promulgation of the Truman Doctrine. Do you know what that is, the Truman Doctrine? No. Okay, well, I'll tell you. This is why you have to read on her, Tom. Yes. So Harry Truman, little man, former haberdasher from Kansas City
关于杜鲁门主义的颁布。你知道那是什么吗，杜鲁门主义？不知道。好吧，那我告诉你。这就是为什么你得读 Unherd 上的文章，汤姆。是的。所以哈里·杜鲁门，这个身材矮小的人、来自堪萨斯城的曾任男装店老板的人，
who's shot and bust after two years, is catapulted into the US presidency in 1945. So that's when Roosevelt dies. When Roosevelt dies. And then there's that sort of muddy period at the end of the Second World War and the beginning of the Cold War. And then in 1947,
在经历了两年籍籍无名之后，于1945年被戏剧性地推上了美国总统的宝座。也就是罗斯福逝世的时候。罗斯福逝世时。然后是第二次世界大战结束和冷战开始之间那段有些混乱的时期。接着在1947年，
he gets up in front of a joint session of Congress and he basically says, we're in a global conflict with the Soviet Union. We're going to give loads of money to Greece and Turkey to stave off communism. We can't allow them to force communism. And then basically we've got a new policy, which is containing communism wherever it is.
他在国会参众两院联席会议上面发表讲话，基本上表示：我们正在与苏联进行一场全球冲突。我们要向希腊和土耳其提供巨额资金，以阻止共产主义。我们不能允许他们强行推行共产主义。然后基本上我们有了一项新政策，那就是在共产主义出现的任何地方遏制它。
We're not fighting it militarilyarily but using economic political and cultural pressure to draw a line between the free world and the totalitarian world and it'll be a long struggle and one day we'll win and so dominic when you wrote this were you aware of any contemporary potential i was of course and this was very much in because tom we're in the not dissimilar position to the one tr was in in 1947. So Stalin didn't have nuclear weapons at that point. They were two years away. But, you know, the Red Army was massive
我们不是在军事上与他们对抗，而是利用经济、政治和文化压力，在自由世界和极权世界之间划清界限。这将是一场漫长的斗争，总有一天我们会赢。所以多米尼克，当你写这篇文章时，你意识到任何当代的潜在……我当然意识到了，而且这非常契合……因为汤姆，我们的处境和1947年杜鲁门面临的处境颇为相似。当时的斯大林还没有核武器。核武器还在两年之后。但是，你知道，红军极其庞大
and fighting Stalin would have meant millions of casualties. So the Americans and the British didn't want to do it. But they actually had a contingency plan, but they knew it would be incredibly costly. So the same sort of deterrent was still there. And I think you could argue that Truman's genius and Clement Attlee in Britain and Ernest Bevan, the founders of NATO, was that they said basically it'll be a long campaign, very grueling. And it means, in a way, condemning a lot of people to live under communism in regimes they don't want, in a world of lies and all that sort of stuff. But in the long run, we can do it and it
与斯大林开战将意味着数百万人的伤亡。所以美国人和英国人都不想这么做。但他们实际上有一个应急计划，而且他们知道代价会极其高昂。所以同样的威慑依然存在。我认为你可以这样认为：杜鲁门的，还有英国的克莱门特·艾 Attlee 和欧内斯特·贝文（北约创始人们）的过人之处在于，他们基本上说过，这将是一场漫长的战役，非常煎熬。在某种程度上，这意味着注定有许多人将在他们不希望的极权政权下生活在共产主义之中，生活在一个充满谎言等等诸如此类的世界里。但从长远来看，我们可以做到，而且
will be worth it so i think there is a there is a good lesson there actually okay i don't i mean people should obviously read your article go to unheard.com u-n-h-e-r-d yeah um good but do you have any do you draw any optimistic conclusions yes i do i do okay i'll tell you what i'd say tom i will tell you what i'd say tom i will tell you what i'd say okay i will have my say uh i say harry truman has already seen off lenin and stalin even in death he can see off vladimir putin as well well there is a thought and if you would um like to read articles of a similar quality to dominates in what i'm sure is the ongoing campaign that all of us are engaged in
这是值得的。所以我觉得这其实是一个很好的教训。好吧，我不是说……人们显然应该读读你的文章，去unheard.com，域名是u-n-h-e-r-d。是的，嗯，很好。但你有什么……你有没有得出什么乐观的结论？是的，我有，我有的。好吧，我来告诉你我想说什么，汤姆。我来告诉你我想说什么，汤姆。我来告诉你我想说什么。好吧，我要发表我的看法。呃，我说哈里·杜鲁门已经送走了列宁和斯大林，即使在死后，他也能送走弗拉基米尔·普京。好吧，这倒是个想法。如果你想读到……呃，水平和多米尼克不相上下、文章质量相当的文章的话，在我确信我们所有人都在参与的这场持续的战役中
to stave off herd mentality you go to unheard.com u-n-h-e-r-d and if you are a restless history listener slash rest you type in slash rest and you get three months for free yeah and normally tom it is a one pound a week a week i mean that's good value in itself but to have it for free isn't that's just yeah yeah and often absolutely not to be missed so many thanks to unheard and now let's get back to whatever it is whatever it is we're talking about they're going to mexico which i cannot understand that that was queen victoria commenting on um maximilian and carlotta that's very liam neeson straight creepy boy i thought actually tom but there you go it was queen victoria everyone would know that was queen victoria i mean obviously
为了摆脱随波逐流的思维定势，你可以访问unheard.com，字母是u-n-h-e-r-d。如果你是一个对历史欲罢不能的听众，斜杠……你输入斜杠rest，就可以免费获得三个月。是的，通常情况下，汤姆，这是一周一英镑。这本身就很划算，但是能免费获得，难道不……这简直是……是的，是的。而且通常绝对不容错过。非常感谢Unheard。现在让我们回到刚才的话题，不管我们在谈论什么。他们正要去墨西哥，我实在无法理解——那是维多利亚女王对……马克西米利安和卡洛塔的评论。这听起来真有点像连姆·尼森那种让人毛骨悚然的小男孩，汤姆，不过话说回来，那是维多利亚女王，每个人都知道那是维多利亚女王，我的意思是，很显然
you're queen victoria now going to mexico which i cannot understand. But enough of that. Ed, we have Maximilian and Carlotta are heading off to Mexico. And this is a Mexico that has basically been, it's under French occupation. Is that right? Or most of it is, the central part of it is. That's a good way of describing it, Tom. So the reason why Napoleon III had accepted it and Maximilian Carlotta too, is because it thought that it would be fairly easy to put into practice. In fact,
你现在是维多利亚女王了，要去墨西哥，这我实在无法理解。不过闲话少说。埃德，马克西米利安和卡洛塔正启程前往墨西哥。而这是一个基本上已经……处于法国占领之下的墨西哥。是这样吗？还是说大部分是这样，其中部地区是这样？这是一个很好的描述方式，汤姆。拿破仑三世之所以接受它，马克西米利安和卡洛塔也接受它，是因为他们认为将其付诸实践会相当容易。事实上，
it's a massive undertaking that requires regime change. So Napoleon III, in 1862, he only sent 6,000 troops. That's how easy he thinks it's going to be to work his way up from Veracruz to Mexico City and the overland route, same route that the conquistadors did. And is that because he's kind of influenced by the story of Cortez conquering the Aztecs? I mean, is this kind of idea that it's really easy to conquer Mexico City? That looms so large in the minds of the soldiers and in the mind of Napoleon III. All I would say as a caveat to that is that the US Expeditionary Force
这是一项需要进行政权更迭的宏大工程。因此，拿破仑三世在1862年只派出了6000名士兵。他觉得从韦拉克鲁斯一路打到墨西哥城并沿着陆路进发会有多容易，这条陆路和当年征服者走的是同一条路线。这是因为他受到了科尔特斯征服阿兹特克人故事的影响吗？我的意思是，这种认为征服墨西哥城易如反掌的想法，在士兵们和拿破仑三世的心中占据了如此分量吗？我对此唯一的保留意见是，美国远征军
that fights its way along exactly the same route, there's only one route to Mexico City from Veracruz, right, you're going to take, is only about 12,000 men. So Napoleon III sent half that, but what he thinks will happen is that Mexican monarchists, Mexican conservatives will rally to the French flag. And therefore, he's got much more support than the United States of America had. So it's part delusion, but partially based on what he thinks happened, you know, a few decades ago, a couple of decades ago of that. These 6,000 troops, they're on their way to Mexico City.
沿着完全相同的路线一路打过去——从韦拉克鲁斯到墨西哥城只有一条路，对吧，你只能走这条路——也只有大约12,000人。所以拿破仑三世派出的兵力只有这个数字的一半，但他认为会发生的情况是，墨西哥保皇党人和墨西哥保守派会团结在法国国旗下。因此，他得到的支持要比美利坚合众国多得多。所以这部分是幻想，但部分也是基于他认为发生过的事情，你知道的，几十年前，也就是一二十年前的事情。这6000名士兵正在前往墨西哥城的路上。
And to get there, you have to go past Mexico's great second city, Puebla. And the French commander is incredibly confident because remember, this is the French army that defeated the Russians in Crimea, defeated the Austrians in 1859. And so he deploys before this city, magnificent churches and convents. You'd love it, Tom. And gives the order for wave after wave of French troops just to attack frontal assault onto the city. But they are cut down by the heroic resistance of Benito Juarez's army, which, of course, has remained loyal to the constitutional president rather than rallying to the flag of a French invader. So that's just the key. And that's, sorry, by the way,
要想到达那里，你必须经过墨西哥的第二大城市普埃布拉。法国指挥官极其自信，因为记住，这可是曾在克里米亚击败俄国人、在1859年击败奥地利人的法军。因此他在座座宏伟的教堂和修道院这座城市前排兵布阵——汤姆，你一定会喜欢这里的——并下达命令，让一波又一波的法军对这座城市发起正面强攻。但他们却被贝尼托·华雷斯军队的英勇抵抗所击溃，这支军队当然保持了对宪法总统的忠诚，而不是去投靠法国侵略者的旗帜。所以这只是关键所在。而且，对不起，顺便说一句，
I should say that goes down in history as Cinco de Mayo, because that's on the 5th of May. It's a Mexican national holiday, isn't it? I mean, I still remember it. It's often, it's often, it is, it's a big deal, but it's often mistaken for Mexican independence. It's not, it's actually celebrating this victory at the Battle of Puebla. So that gives you an indication of how difficult the situation is. And so difficult is it that that pacification, which is the euphemism the French use for their brutal counter-insurgency tactics, it takes another year for them to get to Mexico City. And it takes yet another year for Maximilian and Carlotta to make the voyage across to Mexico. So they don't get there until May 1864. And Ed, I mean, there are some hilariously badly
我应该说，这在历史上被称为五月五日节，因为那是5月5日。这是墨西哥的一个全国性假日，对吧？我的意思是，我还记得。人们经常……它经常……这是一个大日子，但人们常常把它误认为是墨西哥独立日。并不是，它实际上是为了庆祝普埃布拉战役的这场胜利。这就向你表明了局势有多么困难。局势如此艰难，以至于法国人用来形容其残酷反游击战术的委婉词“绥靖”，又花了一年时间才让他们抵达墨西哥城。而马克西米利安和卡洛塔又花了一年时间才完成前往墨西哥的航行。所以他们直到1864年5月才到达那里。埃德，我的意思是，这个故事里有一些举止极其荒唐恶劣的
behaved Frenchmen in this story. So there's this diplomat, Dubois de Saligny, who's, I mean, he seems the worst diplomat in diplomatic history. I mean, his chief talent seems to be for offending people. There's a general, General Foiret, who is so fat that a chair collapses under him. And then there's this terrifying colonel who whose kind of counterinsurgency record is reminiscent of the Battle of Algiers. I mean, this is it's not a kind of dream team, is it? A French dream team in terms of nation building. It's not a great it's not a dream team for nation building at all. And the counterinsurgency colonel Charles Dupin is an extraordinary figure. It's sort of the reverse of General Gordon, although actually perhaps not in one way.
法国人。比如这个外交官杜布瓦·德·萨利尼，我的意思是，他似乎是外交史上最糟糕的外交官。我的意思是，他的主要才能似乎就是得罪人。还有一个将军，福瓦雷将军，胖得连椅子都在他屁股底下塌了。然后还有一个可怕的上校，他的反游击战绩让人想起阿尔及尔战役。我的意思是，这并不是一个梦想团队，对吧？在国家建设方面的一个法国梦想团队。在国家建设方面，这绝对算不上一个伟大的梦想团队。那个反游击战上校夏尔·迪潘是一个非凡的人物。这有点像戈登将军的反面，虽然实际上也许在某种程度上并不完全是。
But one of his fellow French officers said of Dupin, he had all the vices known to man except for drink. But actually, I think that makes it slightly more terrifying because he's put in charge of counterinsurgency. He was actually thrown out of the French army, not for looting the Summer Palace in Beijing. So he was in the Opium Wars, of course he was. Mexico is a conflict that drags in the sort of the dregs and soldiers of fortunes and various imperialist ventures. Now, he was, unlike General Gordon, he was, he was, you know, leading the charge. He's literally one of the first in and first out with as much loot as he could. He then went back to Paris and just openly sold it, which even for the Second Empire, Napoleon III was considered corruption too much. So he was kicked out of the French army. But when he heard they
但迪潘的一位法国同僚曾这样评价他：“除了酗酒，人类所知的各种恶习他全都有。”但实际上，我觉得这反而让他显得更可怕了，因为他被任命负责反游击战。他其实是被法军开除的，不是因为洗劫了北京的圆明园——所以他参加过鸦片战争，他当然参加过。墨西哥是一场将各种残渣余孽、唯利是图的士兵和各种帝国主义冒险活动都拖入其中的冲突。现在，他不像戈登将军那样，他是冲在最前面的那种人。他绝对是第一批冲进去、又带着尽可能多的战利品第一批撤出来的人之一。然后他回到巴黎，公开变卖这些战利品，以至于即便对拿破仑三世的第二帝国而言，这也算是过分的腐败了。所以他被赶出了法军。但当他听说他们
were going to Mexico, he wrote to Napoleon III and said, well, you know this is the kind of place I excel in. And Napoleon III essentially backs him and gets him off to Mexico, where he sets up this counter guerrilla unit to defeat the forces. Benito Juarez, who'd never surrendered, by the way, Benito Juarez is just retreating northwards from Mexico City after the French take the capital. And this is an extraordinary letter that he writes to his niece where he says, I have waged an atrocious war. If I were Mexican, what hatred I would have for the french and how i would make them suffer i think what you don't why would you write that to your niece i don't know i don't i mean i'd like to see what she wrote back thanks for the necklace um what's your thoughts about the war but the serious point is as tom
要去墨西哥时，他写信给拿破仑三世说：“嗯，你知道的，这是我最擅长的领域。”拿破仑三世基本上支持了他，并把他打发去了墨西哥，他在那里建立了一支反游击队来击败这些武装力量。贝尼托·华雷斯，顺便说一句，他从未投降。在法军占领首都后，贝尼托·华雷斯正向墨西哥城以北撤退。这是一封非凡的信，他写给自己的侄女，在信中他说：“我打了一场残酷的战争。如果我是墨西哥人，我对法国人该会有多大的恨意啊，我会怎样折磨他们啊。”我想，你为什么……你为什么会给侄女写这种信？我不知道，我不知道……我的意思是，我很想看看她回了什么信：“谢谢你的项链，呃，你对这场战争有什么看法？”但严肃的一点是，正如汤姆
says if you're trying if you're trying to win over hearts and minds to use the phrase that would probably be used today in this kind of foreign intervention, having someone who is burning down villages, summarily executing people suspected of aiding Benito Juarez, and generally causing all kinds of trouble is not necessarily the person that you want. And so Maximilian has that problem. How do you win over a population that is potentially hostile anyway, and even more so when they've borne the brunt of the French army? said, everybody in Mexico is absolutely on board with you arriving. And it's only a tiny minority who are making a fuss. And also Napoleon has said, crucially, the British are completely on board with this and they'll support you as well, which is an outright lie. The British have already said, haven't they? We're not going to intervene. We're not going to bail you out if it goes wrong.
所说，如果你想争取人心——用今天在这种外国干涉中可能会用到的词来说——找一个烧毁村庄、未经审判就处决涉嫌协助贝尼托·华雷斯的人、并普遍制造各种麻烦的人，这未必是你想要的人。所以马克西米利安就遇到了这个难题。你如何去争取一个本来就可能充满敌意的人心，尤其是当他们承受了法军的沉重打击之后，更是难上加难？（他曾）说过，墨西哥的所有人都绝对全力支持你的到来。只有一小撮人在小题大做。而且拿破仑还至关重要地表示，英国人完全赞同这一点，他们也会支持你，而这完全是个谎言。英国人不是已经说过了吗？我们不会干涉。如果事情搞砸了，我们不会出资把你保释出来。
But Maximilian, is it self-delusion or was he genuinely deluded by the French? I think it's a bit of both. I think that he wants to be misled. So Napoleon III does spin an incredibly elaborate diplomatic game. And Napoleon III is a man who loves conspiracies and back channels and smokefield rooms. And so this is a fantastic opportunity for him to really put that into practice. He absolutely misleads Maximilian about the popularity of monarchy in Mexico. And he completely deceives him about the British view. And the British, British is interesting, but slightly ambivalent. Because although, so Palmerston is prime minister at this time.
但马克西米利安，这究竟是自我欺骗，还是他真的被法国人给蒙蔽了？我认为两者兼而有之。我认为他是渴望受到误导。所以拿破仑三世确实编织了一场极其复杂的政治游戏。拿破仑三世是一个热爱阴谋、暗箱操作和烟雾缭绕的密室政治的人。所以这对他来说是一个绝佳的机会，可以真正将这一点付诸实践。他完全误导了马克西米利安，让他误以为君主制在墨西哥很受欢迎。而且他彻底欺骗了马克西米利安，让他对英国的看法产生了误解。英国人的态度嘛，英国人的态度很有趣，但又有点矛盾。因为尽管——帕麦斯顿当时是首相。
And although no lover of the French, he's absolutely no lover of the United States of America. And so when this plan is put to him, he says, well, it will cost tens of millions of pounds and would have to send 20,000 troops. No way Britain would do that. But if France wants to push back the power of the United States of America for us, we shouldn't, you know, that would be fantastic. So actually, Russell, his foreign secretary, wants to write a letter to Maximilian because Maximilian's condition of accepting the crown is British support. And Palmer says, no, no, no, no, no. Don't write the letter. Keep it ambiguous.
尽管他不是法国人的爱慕者，但他绝对更不是美利坚合众国的爱慕者。所以当这个计划摆在他面前时，他说，这得花上千万英镑，还得派遣两万名军队。英国绝不可能这么做。但如果法国想为我们遏制美利坚合众国的力量，我们不应该……你知道的，那将棒极了。所以事实上，他的外交大臣罗素想给马克西米利安写信，因为马克西米利安接受王位的条件是得到英国的支持。而帕麦斯顿说：“不，不，不，不，不。不要写这封信。保持含糊其辞。”
Keep it ambiguous. So Maximilian, he is misled. But there's, you know, there's sort of a lot of intrigue going on, which is probably, you know, it's slightly above anything that he would be able to comprehend. But Ed, so you have a brilliant passage in your book where you describe how Maximilian Carlotta and all their gang come from Veracruz to Mexico City. And they all have to kind of get off a train and get picked up by mules. And you describe it, this caravan presented an extraordinary sight, the elite of Habsburg society dressed in the finest European fashions, driven towards the capital by local muleteers, clothed in leather jackets, goatskin trousers, and wide gold trim sombreros. And that's what I mean about the kind of magical realist quality,
保持含糊其辞。所以马克西米利安被误导了。但是，你知道的，这里面有很多阴谋诡计在发生，这可能……你知道的，有点超出了他所能理解的范畴。不过埃德，你的书里有一个精彩的段落，描写了马克西米利安、卡洛塔和他们的一帮随从是如何从韦拉克鲁斯来到墨西哥城的。他们都得从火车上下来，然后坐骡车。你这样描写道：“这支车队呈现出一幅非凡的景象，哈布斯堡王朝的精英们身着欧洲最精美的时装，由当地的骡夫驱动着驶向首都，这些骡夫穿着皮夹克、山羊皮裤和宽边金饰宽边帽。”这就是我所说的魔幻现实主义的特质，
because it's the conjunction of these two fabulously remote and different worlds coming together that just kind of seems to generate. I mean, it's a kind of tragic comedy, isn't it? Don't they have like, they have hundreds of pieces of luggage. I mean, they basically brought everything with them. And they've also brought, am I right in thinking they brought their own personal orchestra conductor? Well, you can't go to, of course.
因为这是两个极其遥远、截然不同的世界交汇在一起，似乎自然而然地产生了一种……我的意思是，这是一种悲喜剧，对吧？他们是不是带了……他们带了数以百计的行李。我的意思是，他们基本上把所有东西都带来了。而且他们还带来了……我没记错的话，他们还带来了自己的私人乐团指挥？嗯，你不能去……当然了。
I mean, you can't go to, you can't be an emperor without that. I mean, they just have clearly no clue. Are we, or are we being too harsh? And billiards, billiards tables. Billiard tables, exactly. The brilliant thing that if a guest loses, Maximilian forces him to crawl under the table as a forfeit but if maximilian loses then a servant does it for him i mean this is this is quality emperorship
我的意思是，你不能去……没有那个你就不能当皇帝。我的意思是，他们显然毫无头脑。是我们……还是我们太严苛了？还有台球，台球桌。台球桌，没错。绝妙的一点是，如果有客人输了，马克西米利安会强迫他爬到桌子底下作为惩罚；但如果马克西米利安输了，就会由仆人代劳。我的意思是，这就是优质的皇帝风范
it is isn't it so there are there are many reasons that um maximilian is not necessarily the man for the job because he's faced with an extraordinary situation and difficult problems and to overcome them require a man of equally extraordinary ability and there are elements to him which as you say lend themselves to to farce and one of them is his obsession with etiquette and court ceremony uh hence why you need to have your orchestra with you because you need to have the right music playing at the right time so on the long sea voyage over to mexico where you think that he might in fact be you know reading up on on the history and politics of the country he's about to rule he actually spends most of his time writing a 600 page guide to the etiquette that will be followed at his court it's so important it's well that's the thing but so you can some you know his
对吧？确实如此。所以，马克西米利安之所以未必是这份工作的合适人选，有很多原因，因为他面对的是一种非凡的局势和棘手的问题，而要克服这些问题，需要一个同样具有非凡能力的人。他身上有一些特质，正如你所说，让人觉得有点滑稽，其中之一就是他对礼仪和宫廷仪式的痴迷。因此，你需要把乐团随身携带，因为你需要在正确的时间播放正确的音乐。所以在横渡大海前往墨西哥漫长的航程中，你本以为他可能会去了解他即将统治的国家的历史和政治，但实际上他大部分时间都在写一本长达600页的宫廷礼仪指南。这太重要了……嗯，就是这样。所以你可以……你知道的，他的
enemies of course they wouldn't it's absurd that he's he's he's worried about you know what shoes to wear but um what you the other thing this course is that etiquette is incredibly important to monarchy. And as Tom was saying earlier, partially it is the image. It's the pomp and the ceremony. And there is no court in Mexico because it's a republic. So in order for that to be established, it has to be created. And monarchy is so much depends, doesn't it, on that outward appearance of sort of grandeur and majesty. But there's a paradox, isn't there, about Maximilian, which is that although we're making him sound a kind of very stiff, pompous, faintly foolish figure,
敌人当然会觉得这很荒谬，他竟然在担心该穿什么鞋之类的事情。但是，这件事的另一面是，礼仪对君主制来说极其重要。正如汤姆刚才所说，在某种程度上，这就是形象。这就是排场和仪式。墨西哥没有宫廷，因为这是一个共和国。所以为了确立这一点，它必须被创造出来。而君主制在很大程度上取决于那种宏大和威严的外在表象，不是吗？但关于马克西米利安，有一个悖论，对吧？那就是，尽管我们把他描绘成一个极其古板、自命不凡、略显愚蠢的人物，
and although he's been sponsored by Napoleon III, and although he's been backed by the monarchists, in fact, he's a very, very liberal figure. I mean, and not just by the standards of the Habsburgs. I mean, you know, by anybody's standards. And he brings in a whole range of remarkably progressive laws, among which, am I right, he's the first person to introduce a legally guaranteed lunch break? I'm not sure whether he's the first person. I mean, that is a Corbynite measure, isn't it?
而且尽管他是受拿破仑三世资助的，尽管他得到了保皇党人的支持，但事实上，他是一个非常非常开明的人物。我的意思是，不仅按哈布斯堡王朝的标准来看是这样，我的意思是，按任何标准来看都是如此。他引入了一系列非常进步的法律，其中……我没记错的话，他是第一个引入法律保障的午休时间的人吗？我不敢说他是不是第一个人。我的意思是，那是一个科尔宾式的政策，不是吗？
He does. He takes incredible. So this is, but again, it sort of backs Fireship. So you're absolutely right. He is liberal and very progressive by the standards of the day. But of course, the people who have called him to rule over him are these Mexican Catholic conservatives who want to restore the power of the church. Now, that's anathema to Maximilian's way of thinking. And part of the reason why he became so distant to Franz Joseph was exactly because he disagreed over these kind of policies. So when he comes to Mexico, conservatives are expecting, you know, the sort of ultra-maintained Catholic monarchy and autocracy. And what they get is a slightly watered-down version of Benito Juarez's liberalism. He confirms that key policy that Benito Juarez had been fighting for,
他确实这么做了。他采取了令人难以置信的……所以这也是适得其反。你的完全正确，按当代的标准来看，他思想开明且非常进步。但当然，邀请他来统治他们的人，却是那些想要恢复教会权力的墨西哥天主教保守派。这在马克西米利安的思维方式中是绝对不可接受的。他与弗兰茨·约瑟夫变得如此疏远，部分原因正是因为他在这些政策上与对方意见不合。所以当他来到墨西哥时，保守派期望得到的是……你知道的，那种极力维护的天主教君主专制和独裁统治。而他们得到的，却是贝尼托·华雷斯自由主义的一个稍微淡化版本。他确认了贝尼托·华雷斯一直在为之奋斗的核心政策——
the nationalisation of church property, to the horror of his own allies. So what he does... Is that because he genuinely believes that's the right thing to do? Or is it because actually he's politically astute enough to recognise that he has to do that if he wants to keep foundations for his regime? But Tom, I don't think it is astute. You see, now, regular listeners will expect this from me.
教会财产国有化，这吓坏了他自己的盟友。所以他这么做……是因为他真心觉得这是正确的事情吗？还是因为他实际上在政治上足够精明，认识到如果他想稳固自己政权的根基，就必须这样做？但汤姆，我不认为这叫精明。你看，现在，老听众会从我这里料到这一点。
Is there not an argument, Ed, that Maximilian could have prevailed if he'd just been, if he'd really gone all out, all in with the Conservatives, if he'd basically been more partisan and less liberal. A question from Peter Edmund. Would the Emperor Maximilian have been more successful had he been less liberal? Would a fully reactionary monarch, Sandbrook style, have had a better chance?
埃德，难道没有这样一种论点吗：如果马克西米利安当时能够全力以赴、毫无保留地倒向保守派，如果他能基本上变得更具党派倾向、更少一些自由主义色彩，他本可以取得胜利？这是彼得·埃德蒙（Peter Edmund）提出的一个问题。皇帝马克西米利安如果少一点自由主义色彩，会更成功吗？一个桑德布鲁克风格的完全反动君主，会有更好的机会吗？
Yeah, the dream of authoritarian is everywhere. It's a really interesting question. I think in terms of counterfactuals um yeah so we'll be dealing with that point first the thing about i think actually he's he is a genuine liberal but he's also um we've painted him as slightly a buffoonish figure but he's also doing something pragmatic here if the mexican conservatives had been powerful enough to achieve what they wanted to achieve, they would have done it. They lost the civil war and they need the help of France in order to create
是的，专制主义的梦想无处不在。这是一个非常有趣的问题。我认为就反事实而言，嗯，所以我们先处理这一点。关于……我认为实际上他是一个真正的自由主义者，但他也……我们把他描绘成一个略显滑稽的人物，但他在做这件事时也有务实的一面。如果墨西哥保守派有足够的力量去实现他们想要达到的目标，他们早就做了。他们输了内战，他们需要法国的帮助来建立
this monarchical regime. That conservative project has failed. Now he does alienate his conservative allies, but when push comes to shove, they're going, they are going to back him, right? If necessary.
这个君主制政权。那个保守派项目已经失败了。现在他的确疏远了他的保守派盟友，但在关键时刻，他们还是会支持他的，对吧？如果必要的话。
And they, and as we see, they do what the people who will not back him, right, if necessary. And as we see, they do. The people who will not back him, even moderate liberals, will not back a reactionary government in Mexico. And therefore, winning over the Juaristas is something that he genuinely believes is the right thing. He is a moderate liberal, but also is something that might give his empire a much firmer base for the long term. There's another constraint, though, which is in fact Napoleon III, because Napoleon III is very keen not to be seen as reactionary
而且他们，正如我们所见，他们确实这么做了——那些无论如何都不会支持他的人。那些人，甚至连温和的自由主义者，也不会支持墨西哥的一个反动政府。因此，赢得胡亚雷斯派的支持是他真心认为正确的事情。他是一个温和的自由主义者，但这同时也是一件可能会为他的帝国打下更坚实长期基础的事情。然而，还有另一个制约因素，那就是拿破仑三世本人，因为拿破仑三世非常不愿意让自己被视为反动派。
himself. And he refuses to allow, he wouldn't have allowed the conservatives to overturn the nationalization of church property, because that was actually one of the foundational resolutions of the 1789 resolution in France. And Napoleon III, although we think of him as autocratic and dictatorial, he himself saw himself as ploughing a sort of middle road between liberalism and conservatism. So there are also constraints on Maximilian. The real counterfactual, sorry, I say real, I mean, I think that's a good one. I think it would have to be combined with something else. And it's that this has to work and happen in 1862. By 1864, you've only got one year until the end of the American Civil War.
他拒绝允许——他本不允许保守派推翻教会财产国有化，因为这实际上是法国1789年革命的根本决议之一。而拿破仑三世，尽管我们认为他专制独裁，但他自己认为是在自由主义和保守主义之间开辟了一条中间道路。所以马克西米利安也受到了种种制约。真正的反事实——抱歉，我说真正的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个很好的假设。我认为这必须结合其他因素。那就是这一切必须在1862年运作并发生。到了1864年，距离美国内战结束就只有一年时间了。
And so that geopolitical space to carve out a monarchy on the borders of the United States of America is quickly vanishing. So what Maximilian has got into basically is a situation of an incredibly narrow time window, colossal constraints, his foreign patron, the issues on the ground, all this stuff. and also the fact i mean do you not think though ed he's a i mean he is out totally out of his depth isn't he i mean this is this kind of situation that he's never ever had to deal with as franz joseph's younger brother when he was running the austrian navy or whatever i mean all this stuff about sort of rebranding himself as the champion of the indigenous people and dressing as a cowboy and whatnot i mean these are all they're bound to fail aren't they or am i being
因此，在美利坚合众国边境开辟君主国的地缘政治空间正在迅速消逝。所以马克西米利安基本上陷入了一种极其狭窄的时间窗口、巨大的制约因素、他的外国赞助人、实地的种种问题以及所有这些乱七八糟的事情之中。还有事实是……我的意思是，你不觉得吗，埃德，他……他真的是彻底力不从心了，对吧？我的意思是，这种情况是他作为弗兰茨·约瑟夫的小弟弟在管理奥地利海军或诸如此类的事情时从未应对过的。所有这些把自己重新包装成原住民捍卫者、穿着牛仔装之类的把戏，我的意思是，这些注定会失败，对吧？还是说我太
too harsh well but but isn't also i mean he's he's gone in there to he's under an obligation to napoleon iii to pay back this debt yeah that has been kind of ticking away i mean that's never going to be popular is it no well of course of course and i think the other thing to bear in mind is his opponent, that man we talked about earlier, Benito Juarez, who is absolutely determined that he will never give in to the forces of European imperialism, monarchy, and ultimately Maximilian's back as conservatism.
严苛了？不过——但这也是因为……他去那里是背负着向拿破仑三世偿还这笔债务的义务的，这笔债务一直在像定时炸弹一样倒计时。我的意思是，这永远不会受欢迎，对吧？不，当然，当然。我认为另一件需要牢记的事情是他的对手，我们之前谈到的那个人——贝尼托·华雷斯，他坚决不向欧洲帝国主义、君主制以及最终支持马克西米利安的保守势力屈服。
In fact, Benito Juarez, his former foreign minister, urges Benito Juarez to resign. He says there's no way you will be able to defeat Maximilian back by the French. We have to come to an accommodation. And look, Maximilian's liberal anyway. And Benito Juarez completely rejects it. So I think it's also the opponent that he's dealing with that makes this difficult. The resistance is determined and heroic. But for a brief while, I mean, what, a year, a couple of years, things kind of go okay. You know know he brings in measures he has them translated into nahuatl the language of the aztecs and all this kind of
事实上，贝尼托·华雷斯的前外交大臣曾敦促贝尼托·华雷斯辞职。他说，你根本不可能战胜有法国支持的马克西米利安。我们必须达成妥协。你看，马克西米利安本来就很开明。而贝尼托·华雷斯完全拒绝了这一点。所以我认为，正是他所面对的这个对手，才让事情变得如此艰难。这种抵抗是坚定而英勇的。但有那么一小段时间，我是说，什么，一年、几年，事情似乎还算顺利。你知道，他推行了一些政策，把它们翻译成纳瓦特尔语——阿兹特克人的语言，还有所有这些乱七八糟的东西，
stuff and it's all ticking along and then and then it all starts to crumble and is that um is that due to circumstances within mexico or is it the is it the effect of the ending of the american civil war or uh it's both french In fact, all three. So the fact that Benito Juarez has been able to hold out for as long as he has and is undefeated is crucial. It buys him and the Republican forces in Mexico time that they need. And what they need desperately is more money and they need resupply as well in terms of munitions. And they get that with the end of the American Civil War. During the American Civil War, there's an arms embargo. And as we said, Lincoln is desperate not to do anything to offend France, lest he might tip the balance in his own internal conflict.
一切都在按部就班地进行，然后……然后这一切开始崩塌。是因为墨西哥内部的环境，还是美国内战结束的影响，或者……两者兼有，法国人……事实上，这三者都有。因此，贝尼托·华雷斯能够坚持这么久且未被击败，这是至关重要的。这为他以及墨西哥的共和力量争取到了他们所需要的时间。他们迫切需要的是更多的资金，在军火方面也需要补给。而他们随着美国内战的结束而得到了这些。在美国内战期间，存在武器禁运。正如我们所说，林肯极力避免做任何冒犯法国的事，以免在自己的内部冲突中倾斜天平。
Once that's over, the arms embargo is lifted. Huaristas have access to guns, they have access to money, and they can begin to resupply. Also, crucially, what Washington can now do is pressure Napoleon III. And we can now start talking about the Monroe Doctrine without fear of any meaningful French reprisal, which is exactly what happens. get your troops out of Mexico or it's war. At the same time, Maximilian, not least because of his penchant for orchestras and champagne and interior design and decoration and making all these wonderful residences, his government is bankrupt. So he writes to Napoleon III at the end of the year 1865 as well and says, oh, by the way, the payments that we agreed
一旦战争结束，武器禁运就被解除了。胡亚雷斯派拥有了枪支，拥有了资金，他们可以开始补充物资了。同样至关重要的是，华盛顿现在可以向拿破仑三世施压了。我们现在可以开始谈论门罗主义，而不用害怕任何实质性的法国报复了，事实也正是如此：从墨西哥撤军，否则就是战争。与此同时，马克西米利安的政府已经破产了，这很大程度上是因为他偏爱管弦乐队、香槟、室内设计和装饰，以及建造所有这些漂亮的住所。所以在1865年底，他也写信给拿破仑三世说：“哦，顺便说一句，我们为了让法军留在墨西哥而商定的款项，我再也付不起了。当然，我们是朋友，所以这没关系。你能帮我把它垫付了吗？”这看起来很不妙。
to keep the French army in Mexico, I can't make them anymore. Obviously, we're friends, so it doesn't matter. Can you just cover it for me so that's looking bad that's looking bad and then um Carlotta goes to Europe right right so she's she's she's been uh she she's really loved being an empress I mean she's a great great hostess she's had an absolute ball I mean often literally yeah often literally but she she so she now goes back to Europe, and that's partly to kind of finesse things with Napoleon III.
这看起来很不妙，然后……卡洛塔去了欧洲，对吧？没错。所以她……她一直……她真的很喜欢当皇后。我的意思是，她是个极好的女主人，她过得绝对开心。我的意思是，字面意思上经常如此。是的，字面意思上经常如此。但她……所以她现在回到了欧洲，部分是为了跟拿破仑三世把事情拉近乎。
But that's also, she's already said to Maximilian, hasn't she, Tom, that you can't abdicate. You know, basically like Theodora with Justinian in the Byzantine Empire, you know, the purple is a great winding sheet or whatever. I'd rather die an emperor than live as a slave. But he agrees, a true Habsburg never leaves his post in the moment of danger. But anyway, so she heads off to Europe and it goes badly wrong. It does. So when Maximilian finds out that Napoleon III is going to abandon him,
但这也是因为她已经对马克西米利安说过这话了，对吧，汤姆？你不能退位。你知道的，基本上就像拜占庭帝国的狄奥多拉对查士丁尼所说的那样，你知道的，“紫色长袍是最好的裹尸布”或者诸如此类的话。我宁愿作为皇帝死去，也不愿作为奴隶活着。但他同意了，真正的哈布斯堡家族成员绝不会在危险时刻离开岗位。不管怎样，她动身前往欧洲，结果事情大错特错。确实如此。因此，当马克西米利安发现拿破仑三世要抛弃他时，
he does rather petulantly say, well, I'll find, I'll abdicate if you don't want me here. Carlotta is furious and she says, no, you must stay there and convinces him exactly of what you say to him, that a houseboat never leaves his post. So resolved to stay, she'll go to Paris and she'll persuade Napoleon III to change his mind. So she voyages over in the summer of 1866 and arrives in France. I have a lot of sympathy. We've all been in this situation, haven't we, with Napoleon III. He does everything he can to avoid this meeting. No one likes to be reminded of their foreign policy mistakes.
他确实带着孩子气地说道：“好吧，如果你不想要我在这里，我就退位好了。”卡洛塔勃然大怒，她说：“不，你必须呆在那里。”并向他确凿地灌输了你对他说过的话——哈布斯堡家族的人绝不会离开自己的岗位。既然下定决心要留下来，她决定去巴黎说服拿破仑三世改变主意。所以她在1866年夏天乘船远渡重洋，抵达了法国。我深表同情。我们都经历过这种处境，不是吗，面对拿破仑三世。他想尽一切办法来避免这次会面。没有人喜欢被提醒自己犯下的外交政策错误。
And so he says, well, I'm not feeling very well. And why wouldn't you rather speak to this person? And perhaps we can do the next one. Oh, I've got COVID. I'm isolating. Eventually he's shamed into it. And Carlotta, as we said, her favorite subjects are religion and classics.
所以他说：“嗯，我感觉不太舒服。你为什么不跟这个人谈谈呢？也许我们可以安排下一次。哦，我感染了新冠。我正在自我隔离。”最终他被羞辱得不好意思再推脱了。而卡洛塔，正如我们所说，她最喜欢的科目是宗教和古典文学。
So she's done her homework. She's brought letters that Napoleon III had written to Maximilian saying, you know, my support will never fail you. Now, of course, earlier in the year, Napoleon III has announced publicly that his support has massively failed and that French troops are coming home. So Carlotta brings these letters out and puts them in front of Napoleon III, an incredibly dramatic meeting. And Napoleon III starts crying, but he doesn't change his mind. He doesn't change his mind. Don't know, shaking his head. It's such Gallic conduct.
所以她做足了功课。她带来了拿破仑三世写给马克西米利安的信，信中说：“你知道的，我的支持永远不会辜负你。”当然，今年早些时候，拿破仑三世已经公开宣布，他的支持已经大打折扣，法军正在回国。于是卡洛塔拿出这些信，摆在拿破仑三世面前，这是一次极其戏剧性的会面。拿破仑三世开始哭泣，但他并没有改变主意。他没有改变主意。不知道，一直在摇头。这种举止太具有高卢特色了。
I mean, it's like this podcast, the story of this podcast could have been written by Dr. Johnson or somebody. And actually, there's a moment where a servant comes in and serves refreshments. And it slightly sort of befuddles Carlotta. And then she sort of talks herself out of it. She says, I see what's happened. Your ministers are forcing you to do this. It's not your decision. Let me speak with them.
我的意思是，就像这个播客……这个播客的故事本可以由约翰逊博士或什么人来写。事实上，有一个时刻，一个仆人进来送茶点。这让卡洛塔感到有点困惑。然后她自己把这事说通了。她说：“我明白了发生了什么。是你的大臣们在逼你这么做。这不是你的决定。让我跟他们谈谈吧。
I'll convince them, and they'll convince you. And Hermione says, absolutely. I will set up those meetings. You can have a whole suite of rooms to do whatever you want. And, of course, foreign policy is to preserve the emperor anyway. But his ministers never supported it in the first place.'s hugely unpopular in france the decision stands but carlotta's got one trick left up her sleeve which is to go to the vatican and have a meeting with the pope because as we said maximilian's liberal policies have alienated his core catholic
我会说服他们，然后他们会说服你。”而拿破仑三世说：“完全可以。我会安排这些会面。你可以拥有整套房间来做你想做的事。”当然，外交政策无论如何都是为了保住皇帝。但他的大臣们一开始就从未支持过这一点。这在法国非常不受欢迎。这一决定依然有效。但卡洛塔还有最后一招，那就是去梵蒂冈与教皇会面，因为正如我们所说，马克西米利安的自由主义政策疏远了他核心的天主教保守派选民。
conservative constituency but if they are backed by the Pope, then, of course, that brings the Catholics in Mexico on board. So there's still hope. She travels overland to Rome and arrives there. I think it's in September of 1866. The first meeting goes relatively, relatively unproblematically. It's the second meeting where things begin to unravel because she's the pressure is enormous. She's convinced her husband to stay in Mexico. The empire looks like it's falling apart. And this mission with the Pope is crucial. She can't wait for it. And her health is beginning to suffer. And she demands to be driven to the Vatican. Unannounced, she breaks into the Vatican. I mean, how do you stop the Empress of Mexico if
但如果他们得到教皇的支持，那么，当然，这就会把墨西哥的天主教徒争取到阵营中来。所以希望犹存。她走陆路前往罗马并在那里抵达。我想那是在1866年9月。第一次会面相对来说比较顺利，没有出什么问题。正是在第二次会面中，事情开始失控，因为她承受的压力太巨大了。她劝说她的丈夫留在墨西哥，而帝国看起来却在分崩离析。这次与教皇的使命至关重要。她等不及了。而且她的健康状况也开始恶化。她要求乘车前往梵蒂冈。在没有预约的情况下，她强行闯入了梵蒂冈。我的意思是，如果你只是守在门口，怎么可能拦得住墨西哥皇后放她通行呢？她要求见教皇。最终，教皇被惊醒了，大概还穿着教皇的睡袍，然后在梵蒂冈的走廊里……你知道的，到底是怎么回事？迎面撞见了墨西哥皇后。然后她崩溃了，无法控制地啜泣并尖叫起来。
you're just on the door to let them through? Demands to see the Pope. Eventually, the Pope is sort of roused, presumably in his papal pyjamas, and sort of, you know, what's going on in the corridors of the Vatican, confronted with the Empress of Mexico. And she breaks down, uncontrollable sobs, and screaming. And what she's screaming is that Napoleon III is trying to murder her with poison. That her entire entourage that has come with her from Mexico, her servants, Mexican politicians, whoever they be, are in the pay of the French emperor and they're trying to have her killed. Now, of course, Napoleon III, I mean, devious though he may be, has no interest
她尖叫的内容是，拿破仑三世正试图用毒药谋杀她。她从墨西哥带来的整个随从团队、她的仆人、墨西哥政客，无论他们是谁，都收受了法国皇帝的贿赂，正试图置她于死地。现在，当然，拿破仑三世——尽管他可能很狡猾——对毒死卡洛塔没有任何兴趣。而她已经失去了理智。她彻底陷入了妄想和偏执的世界，她把拿破仑三世视为字面意义上的化身恶魔，她是世上邪恶的源头，她是这么称呼他的。现在，这当然不会带来与教皇达成协议、从而将天主教墨西哥团结在背后的结果。所以她的任务失败了。所以事实上，我之前说杜布瓦·德·萨利尼是史上最糟糕的外交官，但也许卡洛塔实际上比他还要糟糕。
in poisoning Carlotta and she's lost her mind. She's completely gone into a world of delusion and paranoia and she sees Napoleon III as literally the devil incarnate, the principle of evil upon earth, she calls him. Now, this, of course, doesn't result in a concordat with the Pope, which we're rallying Catholic Mexico behind. So her mission is failed. So actually, I said Du Bois de Saligny was the worst diplomat of all time, but perhaps Carlotta has actually pipped him.
她没有完成她的任务。但我喜欢你专注于这一点的方式，汤姆。我一直是个优秀的boss，但是……那笔交易呢？成了吗？没有，她实际上被她的比利时家人接走了，并被安置在……嗯，也就是隔离治疗的同义词，那是当时人们认为应对这些精神问题最好的方式。而这当然适得其反。她从未康复，事实上她再也没有回到墨西哥。与此同时，马克西米利安被困在墨西哥，他控制的范围开始缩减并崩溃。所以有人建议他，对吧？去一个叫克雷塔罗的地方，是这样吗？克雷塔罗，是的。
She's not achieved her mission. But I like the way you were focused on that Tom I've been an excellent boss but did you and the deal yes did it come off it doesn't she's actually taken into um taken into care by her Belgian family and put into into you know well the equivalent of isolation which is the way that people thought they were best to deal with these these mental problems in those days and of course was the very opposite she never recovers and in fact she never goes back to mexico but meanwhile maximilian is stuck in mexico and and and the sphere of his control is starting to shrink and collapse and so he gets advised doesn't he to um go to a place called Carretero, is that right? Carretero, yes.
当他听到关于卡洛塔的消息时，他不是又一次动了退位的念头吗？他是的。而且同样地，人们对他说，其他人对他说：“哦，不要退位，你知道的，最好……你是个哈布斯堡家族的人，所有这些乱七八糟的话。”我想他收拾行李了，我没记错的话，他在那个时候收拾了行李。所以同样地，当他听到卡洛塔遭遇了这起可怕的事故、他的妻子生病的消息时，他再次决定退位。所以是第二次。但是我们……我的意思是，我们真的应该强调马克西米利安的特点。他优柔寡断。他拖延。如果不必要做出决定，他就绝不做。总是拖延。但他很勇敢，对吧？我的意思是，他非常勇敢。这一点毋庸置疑。绝对如此。所以他……他非常勇敢，这一点毋庸置疑。所以他……
He's already had another flirtation with abdication, hasn't he, when he hears about Carlotta? He does. And again, people say to him, other people say, oh, don't abdicate, you know, better to, you're a Habsburg, all this sort of stuff. And I think he packed his, am I right to think he packed his bags on that occasion. So again, once he hears the news that Carlotta has had suffered this terrible incident and his wife is sick, he resolves to abdicate again. So second time. But we I mean, we should have really emphasized about Maximilian. He's indecisive. He procrastinates. He doesn't like if you don't have to make a decision, don't make it. Always push it. But he is brave, right? I mean, he is very brave. That comes across. Absolutely. So he's he he is very brave that comes across absolutely so he's
正如多米尼克所说，他被人劝住了。保守派盟友向他承诺了一切：成千上万的军队，数千万美元。一旦法国人撤走，我们就不会背负外国干涉的污名了。想想看，我们如何能击败胡亚雷斯派……是的，不用任何士兵，我们就能……但他确实有一些……我的意思是，他确实有，这就是为什么他最终会去这个地方——克雷塔罗，因为那里有……你知道的，这是保守主义的一个据点。所以一旦法国人离开，就会发生各种让人想起更近一些事件的场景：难民跟在法军后面，一片混乱等等诸如此类。而他们迫切希望马克西米利安和他们一起走。他拒绝了，说：“我要留下来战斗。”就是这样。所以计划是去一个距离墨西哥城西北约130英里的城镇——克雷塔罗。现在，这是一个帝国的据点。
talked out of it as dominic says um the conservative allies promise him everything tens of thousands of men tens of millions of dollars once the french have gone we won't have the stigma of foreign intervention just think how we'll be able to defeat the paristas yeah without any soldiers we'll be so but he does have some doesn't he i mean he does and that's why and that's why he ends up going to this place cuaraterero, because there are, you know, this is a stronghold of conservatism. So once the French have left, and there's all kinds of scenes reminiscent
正如多米尼克所说，他被劝阻了。嗯，保守派盟友向他承诺了一切：成千上万的士兵，数千万美元。一旦法军撤离，我们就不会背负外国干涉的耻辱。想想看，我们将如何击败华雷斯派，是的，不需要任何士兵，我们将……但他确实有一些军队，不是吗？我的意思是，他确实有，这就是为什么他最终会去克雷塔罗这个地方，因为这里你知道的，是保守主义的大本营。所以一旦法军离开，就会出现各种各样的场景，让人联想到
of more recent events where refugees following in the wake of the French army and sort of chaos and so on and so forth. And they desperately want Maximilian to come with them. He refuses to say, I'm going to stay and fight. And that's it. So the plan is to go to a town about 130 miles northwest of Mexico City, Guerrero. Now, this is an imperial stronghold.
更近期的事件，难民紧随法军撤退的脚步，一片混乱等等。他们迫切希望马克西米利安和他们一起走。他拒绝了，说我要留下来战斗。就是这样。所以计划是前往距离墨西哥城西北约130英里的一个城镇——克雷塔罗。现在，这里是一个帝国的坚固堡垒。
There are imperial Easter soldiers, the supporters of Maximilian, imperial Easter's already there. And what's going to happen is this is the plan as it stands. Maximilian will become commander in chief of the army. He will lead a small force out from Mexico City. They will march to the relief of these imperialist. Three Haurisa armies are converging on the city, but you defeat them one by one. And then the empire will be gloriously restored after this dramatic victory over the forces of the empire's atheistic liberals. It sounds like a desperate plan, and it is one. instead of the tens of thousands of men the conservatives managed to scrape together 1500 for maximilian uh to lead northwards and only 50 000 dollars uh which is barely enough to pay the wages of the troops that he's marching to um with
那里有帝国东部士兵，也就是马克西米连的支持者，帝国东部的人已经在那里了。将要发生的是目前的计划。马克西米连将成为军队总司令。他将率领一小支部队从墨西哥城出发。他们将进军去接应这些帝国主义者。三支胡亚雷斯军队正在向该市汇集，但你将逐个击败他们。然后，在取得对帝国无神论自由派军队的这一决定性胜利之后，帝国将带着荣耀复兴。这听起来像是一个绝望的计划，也确实如此。保守派勉强拼凑出的不是几万名士兵，而是只有1500人供马克西米连率领向北进发，资金也只有5万元，这甚至刚刚够支付他正率领部下开赴前线时军队的薪水
rather than um even you know to relieve that force force. And then he goes butterfly hunting. Well, this is it. So Maximilian has never served in an army, let alone commanded one. He's appointed commander-in-chief with the idea that, you know, this victory will be his responsibility and therefore will demonstrate what a wonderful leader he is. Maximilian, he's, I guess,
而不是甚至，你知道的，去解救那支军队。然后他去抓蝴蝶了。好吧，就是这样。所以马克西米连从未在军队服役过，更不用说指挥军队了。他被任命为总司令，其想法是，你知道的，这场胜利将是他的责任，因此将证明他是一个多么出色的领袖。马克西米连，他，我猜，
what one would call a dilettante, although he's, you know, he's interested in natural science and botany and especially butterflies. And it's sort of a fantastic moment. So the territory, call a dilettante although um he's you know he's he's interested in natural science and botany and especially butterflies and a sort of fantastic moment so the the territory his empire has shrunk to the point because while he's prevaricated about whether i should abdicate the juaristas are advancing on all sides and they're taking towns and cities uh and taunting the defenders saying well your emperor's packed as dominic says your emperor's you know he's packed up his furniture
人们会称之为学者或业余爱好者，尽管他，你知道的，他对比自然科学、植物学特别是蝴蝶很感兴趣。这真是一个奇妙的时刻。所以这片领土，被称为业余爱好者，尽管嗯他，你知道的，他对自然科学、植物学特别是蝴蝶很感兴趣，这真是一个奇妙的时刻，所以他的帝国所缩减到的领土，因为当他还在犹豫我是否应该退位时，胡亚雷斯派正在四面推进，他们攻占了城镇和城市，并且嘲笑防守方说，好吧，正如多米尼克所说，你的皇帝已经收拾好行李了，你的皇帝，你知道的，他已经收拾好了家具
and he's off so what on earth are you fighting Plus, they haven't been paid in about a year either. So there's not really much support for him. It's melting away. And so the countryside is held by Khawri's Degreer forces. And so he's constantly under attack on this march. But he's always stopping off for sort of teachable moments about Aztec history that will inspire his troops. Or to look at a rare butterfly that he hasn't catted. I mean, this is where it's very Gabriel Garcia Marquez.
他要走了，所以你们到底还在打什么仗？另外，他们也有一年左右没拿到工资了。因此，对他并没有什么真正的支持。这种支持正在消融。因此，乡村地区都被胡亚雷斯的游击队控制着。所以他在这次行军中不断受到攻击。但他总是停下来，为阿兹特克历史上一段段可以启发军队的教育性时刻驻足。或者去观察一只他还没归类的稀有蝴蝶。我的意思是，这就是非常加西亚·马尔克斯风格的地方。
I think that's how you would behave, Tom. I mean, you would see some sort of interesting fossil, or, you know, you go on one of your walks and look at some old churches. Well, I can tell you, I can tell you, I would have scarpered in his situation. I would absolutely have abdicated. It's a wonderful, wonderful moment.
我觉得你就会那样做，汤姆。我的意思是，你会看到某种有趣的化石，或者，你知道的，你去散步然后看看一些古老的教堂。嗯，我可以告诉你，我可以告诉你，如果在他的处境下，我早就溜之大吉了。我绝对会退位。这是一个非常精彩的时刻。
He's writing letters to his, the director of a museum of natural science, which he's opened. He's a big fan of museums. So there's a lot to like with Maximilian there. And he's talking about the journey and he really does focus on the butterflies. And he says, well, as the bullets were whistling around me, I noticed the most extraordinary butterfly. It's admirable in a certain way. Well, he does show absolute cool, calm and collective courage under fire. And he does show leadership abilities and charisma. And he does lead this horse safely to Carretero. But that then turns out to be, because as I understand it from your book,
他正在给自然科学博物馆的馆长写信，那个博物馆是他开设的。他是博物馆的超级粉丝。所以马克西米连身上有很多讨人喜欢的地方。他谈到了旅程，而且他确实专注于蝴蝶。他说，好吧，当子弹在我的耳边呼啸时，我注意到了一只最不寻常的蝴蝶。在某种程度上，这确实令人钦佩。好吧，他在炮火下确实表现出了绝对的冷静、沉着和勇敢。他也展现出了领导能力和个人魅力。而且他确实把这支骑兵安全地带到了克雷塔罗。但事实证明，据我对你的书的理解，
it's kind of, it's surrounded by heights. And his enemies are able to occupy the heights. And so basically he's stuck there it's the worst place to have a siege surrounded by uh hills on three sides open plain to the west there's a beautiful 18th century aqueduct that brings water and that's very quickly cut the quarries to state the high ground uh and of course the plan to defeat these armies one by one would require decisive action and maximilian which has a council of war prevarication it doesn't happen but even now he could still escape, right?
它有点被高地包围了。他的敌人能够占领这些高地。所以基本上他被困在那里了，这是打围城战最糟糕的地方，三面都被小山环绕，西面则是开阔的平原，有一座美丽的18世纪引水渠可以运送水源，而这很快就被切断了，胡亚雷斯派占据了高地。当然，逐个击败这些军队的计划需要果断的行动，而马克西米连却召开了军事会议进行拖延，行动并没有发生。但即使在现在，他本来还是可以逃跑的，对吧？
Because somebody says to him, don't they, at some point, you know, I've basically got a great plan for you to get away and get out of the town. But Maximilian says, no, no, no, I've invited some local officials. What would they say if they arrived and I was gone? It would be very disrespectful and discourteous of me to leave. Which, again, I think reflects very well on this. Yes, absolutely.
因为有人对他说，不是吗，在某个时刻，你知道的，“我基本上为你制定了一个绝妙的计划，让你离开并逃出小镇。”但马克西米连却说：“不，不，不，我邀请了一些地方官员。如果他们到了而我却不在，他们会怎么说？离开将是对他们非常不尊重和失礼的行为。”再次说明，我认为这很好地反映了这一点。是的，完全如此。
I mean, manners are much more important than saving one's own life. But anyway, so he ends up, and again, you have a fabulous sentence, the Archduke Ferdinand Maximilian, born at the Habsburg Palace of Schönebrunn, offered his sword to Escobedo, a former farm labourer from the harsh Sierras of Nuevo León, which again, it's that conjunction
我的意思是，礼貌比保全自己的性命重要得多。无论如何，他最终——再次说明，你写了一句绝妙的句子：出生在美泉宫哈布斯堡王朝的斐迪南·马克西米连大公，将他的长剑献给了埃斯科贝多，一个来自新莱昂州严酷山脉的前农场工人。这再次体现了
of two totally alien worlds. And he gets, he becomes a prisoner and things take a dark turn for him from that point on. Yes, I understand. The result is not good from his point of view. Yeah, the siege, it was a disaster. He's actually betrayed after two months by one of his most loyal officers, a man that he was godfather to children of, who goes over and took Juarista lines, leased them through. And in the morning of May 15th, 1867, the Juaristas have encircled the town and broken
两个完全格格不入的世界的交汇。他被俘了，从那时起，他的命运急转直下，走向了黑暗。是的，我明白。从他的角度来看，结果并不好。是的，围城战是一场灾难。两个月后，他实际上被他最忠诚的一名军官背叛了，这个人是他孩子的教父，他投靠了胡亚雷斯派的防线，并为他们引路。在1867年5月15日的早晨，胡亚雷斯派已经包围了小镇并突破了
through the Imperial Easter lines and he's put in prison. Court-martialed, which is very much going to be a show trial. It's actually held in a theatre named after the first emperor of Mexico, Itabide. People who've been paying attention will remember that he was also executed. I love the detail in your book where he says, I don't think, I don't really think I want to have a trial. You know, I'm an emperor. And they say, yeah, but people have been, kings have been tried before. Look at Louis XVI. I can't imagine anything less reassuring. I know, and that's from another French diplomat. It's a French diplomat. He desperately doesn't want to go. And she says, yes, but what about Marie Antoinette and Louis XVI? I mean, that was good
帝国东部的防线，他被投入了监狱。随后他接受了军事法庭审判，这很大程度上是一场作秀审判。审判实际上是在一个以墨西哥第一位皇帝伊图比德命名的剧院里举行的。一直在关注的人会记得他也是被处决的。我喜欢你书中的一个细节，他说：“我觉得，我真的不想接受审判。你知道的，我是个皇帝。”他们说：“是的，但以前国王也受过审判。看看路易十六。”我无法想象还有什么比这更让人感到不安的了。我懂，那是另一个法国外交官说的。这是一个法国外交官。他拼命不想去。她却说：“是的，但玛丽·安托瓦内特和路易十六呢？我的意思是，那对他们来说很好”
for them. Charles I, interestingly, is an inspiration for him. I was going to say, very much, well, is he a friend of the show, Charles I? He has an ambiguous relationship. He does, I think. But Ed, here's a question for you. Why do the Mexicans, why are they so set on trying him
查理一世，有趣的是，成为了他的灵感来源。我正要说，查理一世算得上是节目的老朋友吗？他有着一种暧昧的关系。他的确有，我想。不过埃德，我有一个问题要问你。为什么墨西哥人，他们为什么如此坚决要审判他
and executing him? Why don't they just put him on a boat and say, you know, bugger off back to Europe? It's an excellent question. And Maximilian would have been fairly confident that that's what would have happened. Of course, it's something that he's offered to do. He says, you know, I'll applicator go.
并处决他？为什么不直接把他塞进船里，然后对他说，“你知道的，滚回欧洲去吧”？这是一个很好的问题。马克西米连本可以相当自信地认为那正是会发生的事情。当然，这也是他主动提出要做的事情。他说，“你知道的，我会退位并离开。
I promise I won't come back. And if you think about the conflict you have in North America between Union Confederacy, Jefferson Davis, who's committed the most egregious treason you possibly could against the Union, right? He is put in prison, but he's eventually pardoned an amnesty or whatever it is. So that execution is rare. But Benito Juarez, as we said, is made of stern stuff. Now, this conflict in Mexico has been raging almost without interval since 1858. So that's nearly 10 years.
我保证我不会再回来。”如果你想想你在北美经历的联邦与邦联之间的冲突，杰斐逊·戴维斯，他犯下了你可能对联邦犯下的最令人发指的叛国罪，对吧？他被投入了监狱，但最终还是得到了特赦和宽恕什么的。所以这种处决是罕见的。但本尼托·华雷斯，正如我们所说，是个意志坚强的人。现在，墨西哥的这场冲突几乎不间断地肆虐自1858年以来。所以那已经是将近10年了。
And it's not, the fight is not with Maximilian, although, I mean, at this stage, of course it is, but it hadn't begun with Maximilian. It had been with the Conservative Party. Remember, it was just defeated in civil war in 1861. And so the French poured gasoline onto the burning embers of this conflict, which then flared up again. And, you know, tens of thousands of Mexicans have been killed. And Benito Juarez wants to end that conservative resistance to his legitimacy, I suppose, is the way of saying it. And of course, we focus on Maximilian, but he's executed alongside two
而且，这场战斗不是针对马克西米连的，虽然，我的意思是，在这个阶段，当然是的，但它并不是从马克西米连开始的。它是针对保守党的。记住，它在1861年的内战中刚刚被击败。因此，法国人将汽油泼在了这场冲突正在燃烧的余烬上，随后冲突再次爆发。而且，你知道的，成千上万的墨西哥人被杀害了。本尼托·华雷斯想要结束这种对他的合法性的保守派抵抗，我想这是表达这一点的正确方式。当然，我们把焦点放在马克西米连身上，但他是在与另外两个人一起被处决的
other men, Miguel Miramont and Tomás Mejia. And these are both leaders of the Conservative Party representing different strands. Miramont, the Creole landed aristocracy descendants of Spaniards. Mejía, who is another indigenous peoples of Mexico, but that deep strand of pious rural conservatism based on Catholicism. And so you essentially, and Maxman, of course, representing Europe and European monarchy in foreign intervention. And so it is an incredibly determined attempt to put an end to that kind of resistance. And I suppose also to kind of offer, you know, serve as a warning to other European
另两个人是米格尔·米拉蒙和托马斯·梅希亚。他们都是代表不同派别的保守派领袖。米拉蒙代表克里奥尔地主贵族，也就是西班牙人的后裔。梅希亚则代表墨西哥的其他土著人民，以及植根于天主教的那种深厚的虔诚农村保守主义。所以你本质上，而马克西米连，当然代表了欧洲和欧洲君主制以及外国干预。因此，这是一次极其坚决的尝试，旨在彻底结束那种抵抗。我想这也起到了一种……
princelings who may be tempted to pop over and have a crack. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because that monarchy, the idea of monarchy had just been bubbling below the surface in Mexico from the 1840s onwards. So this is what happens if you try and set up a monarchy in Mexico. So Ed, he together with the two conservatives gets hauled in front of a firing squad. They get shot.
为那些可能想过来碰碰运气的其他欧洲小诸侯敲响警钟的作用。对，对，对。因为君主制，君主制的概念在1840年代以后一直在墨西哥地下暗流涌动。所以这就是如果你试图在墨西哥建立君主制会发生的事情。所以，埃德，他同那两个保守派一起被拉到了行刑队前。他们被枪决了。
He's not wearing a sombrero, as Manet shows him wearing. His body is treated quite disrespectfully isn't it uh they don't follow court etiquette they they keep the body in Mexico City and then after the negotiations it goes back to uh to to Vienna they don't follow court etiquette um yeah and she's worth pointing out that Maximilian wrote an emergency court etiquette to be observed during siege uh siege warfare conditions with artilleries raining down. So he always had an eye for etiquette,
他没有戴马奈画中描绘的那种宽边墨西哥帽。他的尸体受到的待遇相当不尊重大多是不体面的，对吧？他们不遵循宫廷礼仪，他们把尸体留在墨西哥城，然后经过谈判后才把它运回维也纳。他们不遵循宫廷礼仪，嗯，值得指出的是，马克西米连曾写过一份紧急宫廷礼仪，供在炮火连天的围城战期间遵守。所以他总是对礼仪有着敏锐的关注，
which is not followed, as you say, after his death. So the body's embalmed, the idea will be sent back to Vienna. Benito Juarez tries to use it as diplomatic leverage, essentially, to get Franz Joseph to recognise the Mexican Republic, because by doing it, by executing Maximilian, Mexico does become something of a rogue state in European eyes for a good 10 years or so before any European court actually recognizes
但在他死后并没有被遵循，正如你所说。所以尸体被进行了防腐处理，计划将其运回维也纳。本尼托·华雷斯试图将其作为外交筹码，本质上是为了让弗朗茨·约瑟夫承认墨西哥共和国，因为通过这样做，通过处决马克西米连，在欧洲人眼中，墨西哥在长达10年左右的时间里确实变成了一个流氓国家，直到任何欧洲宫廷真正承认
the Mexican Republic. And so the body is, it's not treated well, it's kept in Mexico City in rather insalubrious conditions. And it's eventually sent back, I think it's November 1867, so a good few months after the execution. So your book is The Last Emperor of Mexico. We've already said yet, but of course, you know, the likelihood that there'll be another emperor of Mexico is fairly low. So Mexico is a republic to this day. I think we should end just by asking a question from Thomas Henselick, which I was wondering as well. Is there still any remembrance of Maximilian amongst contemporary Mexicans, or has the episode been utterly forgotten? And what role does this episode play in the historical memory of Mexico? No, it's not been forgotten at all. But of course,
墨西哥共和国。因此，尸体并没有受到很好的对待，它被保存在墨西哥城条件相当糟糕的环境中。它最终被运回国，我想那是1867年11月，也就是处决后好几个月。所以你的书是《墨西哥的最后一个皇帝》。我们之前已经说过了，但是当然，你知道，墨西哥出现另一个皇帝的可能性相当低。所以墨西哥至今仍是一个共和国。我想我们最后应该以汤姆·汉斯利克的一个问题来结束，这也是我一直想知道的。在当代的墨西哥人中，是否还有人对马克西米连有任何记忆，还是这段插曲已经被完全遗忘了？这段插曲在墨西哥的历史记忆中扮演了什么角色？不，它一点也没有被忘记。但是当然，
the celebration there is Benito Juarez and all things like Cinco de Mayo. So if you fly into Mexico City, you fly into Benito Juarez Airport. The role that it plays in Mexico in terms of its history is a foundational moment. Independence in the 19th century was contested. Depending on who you spoke to, they'll tell you a different story and about different heroes. The story of Benito Juarez's triumph over the forces of European imperialism, monarchy, and reactionary Catholic conservatism becomes one that most Mexicans, if not all, are able to rally behind. And so it has a unique place in Mexican history, and therefore the story is well known. In terms of
那里的庆祝活动是关于本尼托·华雷斯的，一切都像五月五日节那样。所以如果你飞往墨西哥城，你是飞往本尼托·华雷斯机场。它在墨西哥历史上扮演的角色是一个奠基时刻。19世纪的独立是充满争议的。取决于你和谁谈话，他们会告诉你一个不同的故事以及关于不同的英雄。本尼托·华雷斯战胜欧洲帝国主义、君主制和反动天主教保守派势力的故事，成为了大多数（如果不是全部）墨西哥人能够团结在其身后的故事。因此它在墨西哥历史上占有独特地位，因此这个故事广为人知。就……而言
Maximilian's legacy, it becomes quite, it does become quite romanticised, as you can imagine, with Carlotta and the court. And it's because as you say, it's so exotic, and so almost out of time, even in the 1860s, that it does become the focus of quite a lot of literature
马克西米连的遗产，它确实变得相当浪漫化，正如你可以想象的那样，伴随着卡洛塔和宫廷。这是因为正如你所说，它是如此异国情调，而且甚至在1860年代就已经显得与时代格格不入，以至于它确实成为了大量文学作品的焦点
and film and things like that. So he's remembered very much as being on the wrong side of history and Benicio Juarez as being on the right side. But there is an element as well that his character does shine through in some of the things
以及电影等等。所以人们对他的记忆很大程度上是站在历史错误的一边，而本尼托·华雷斯则站在正确的一边。但也有这样一种因素，即他的性格确实在某些事情中闪耀出光芒
that he's sort of naive and unwelcome, but not perhaps irredeemable in and of himself, I think. Talking of irredeemable, maybe we should end with the villain of the story. Because, I mean, he doesn't have long left himself, does he? Napoleon III. It looks like he sent this man to his doom
他有点天真且不受欢迎，但在他本人身上或许并非不可救药，我想。说到无可救药，也许我们应该以故事中的反派来结束。因为，我的意思是，他自己的时间也不多了，不是吗？拿破仑三世。看起来他把这个人送上了绝路
and basically got away with it. But, I mean, his own imperial ambitions are about to collapse in ashes around him, aren't they? In 1870, 1871? Well, one of Maximilian's last wishes, which was that if he was able to go into exile, he would enrol in the Prussian army and fight against the French. And, of course, that's exactly what happens,
并且基本上逃脱了惩罚。但是，我的意思是，他自己的帝国野心正准备在他身边化为灰烬，不是吗？在1870年、1871年？嗯，马克西米连最后的愿望之一是，如果他能够流亡，他将加入普鲁士军队并与法国作战。而且，当然，这正是发生的
well, except for the fact that he can't enrol in it. So he would have been delighted when Prussian troops streamed across the French border and Napoleon III, who is sort of ironically trapped in a larger version of what happened to Maximilian. But he gets away, doesn't he, and ends up in chisel house. Well, he very sensibly abdicates. He says, ah, I think the game might be up. And Ed, you are currently, I think, writing a book
事情，除了他无法加入这一事实之外。所以，当普鲁士军队冲过法国边境，而拿破仑三世——他具有讽刺意味地被困在马克西米连遭遇的更大版本的事件中时，他一定会欣喜若狂。但他逃脱了，不是吗，最终去了奇西尔豪斯。嗯，他非常明智地退位了。他说，“啊，我想游戏可能要结束了。”埃德，我想你目前正在写一本
about Napoleon III, which, based on the evidence of your wonderful book on Maximilian, is going to be so worth reading. I guess kind of grimly funny, as in so many ways this book is. I can't thank you enough. It's been an absolute tool to force. And just to reiterate, Edward Shawcross, The Last Emperor of Mexico, fantastic book.
关于拿破仑三世的书，根据你关于马克西米连的那本精彩著作来看，这本书非常值得一读。我想这在很多方面都带有一种冷酷的滑稽，正如这本书在许多方面所展现的那样。我再怎么感谢你也不为过。这绝对是一次精彩的演讲。再次重申，爱德华·肖克罗斯的《墨西哥的最后一个皇帝》，非常棒的一本书。
Rush out and buy it. Cheers. Thank you. We should say, I guess, adios. Adios and au revoir. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
赶快去买一本吧。干杯。谢谢。我想我们应该说，再见。再见，保重。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦内幕的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。